everybody it's cold today it is cooled
call my wife she's taking off to go do her
thing
all right we're going to do some NFL stuff
today and how's it going to grieve 23
it is Manifest so I thought we would like
separate out
the NFL stuff if its own learning lab
project
so this is the one there's really nothing
here yet but I will be I'll be sharing this
later with everybody
so what are we going to do in this one well
let's put up with put up the requirements
for that I'll talk about what n f s is
so so create three machines
create three machines actually with the 2 GB
of RAM
333 machines with vagrant with 2 GB Ram
figuring virtual machines
using the virtualbox driver
went to GB RAM and 1 CPU each we don't need
more than that for this particular lab so we
don't need to blow our computer up too much
and include
name the machines control
and node one and
order one in order to
create create a 1 1 GB
volume
I said I can do less than actually we could
say create a
10 MB volume how's it going Justin
a credit created 10 mg volume on
secondary volume and mount
and and exports and exported
as an NFS volume and then mount
mountie
mount a nfsc the volume on the two workers
so that's that's the goal and not yell
and so what is NFS excetera excetera we're
going to have a related section here
so that does give me how we're going to keep
track of stuff call this
under this one will call this one read me so
we can get back to that
so what is NFS first of all I know I'm at
work so I'm I'm going to make this really
brief you know the work the work-study
boundaries is pretty gray in my case because
all the stuff that I'm learning here is
directly related to my job so I don't mind
going over to solidify as my knowledge as
well and it course I'm going to be doing a
lot of stuff over the weekend that is also a
work-related and covid-19 related so lest
anybody worry I'm not technically salary in
but that's pretty much how you would behave
if you were a salaried employee
salaried employees are responsible for
keeping up no matter what it's not
explicitly part of your job description so
let's talk about what what n f s is so any
of us talks SPSS for Network file system
it's a very old technology this got through
many many updates and for a long time it was
considered extremely insecure to use it but
those days are gone and if s is Reese's come
back up in popularity now that we're using
kubernetes
and that's where this this is coming from
and if this really isn't is required for
kubernetes but it's becoming more and more
popular
now that kubernetes doesn't have a real
solid handle on the storage and there has is
never focused on it and so having an FS
volume I'm trying to find a diagram of it
let's go see if we can search for images of
Santa Fest
and you don't answer so I know this is come
back up and popularity we talked we talked
about a lot more lately because of
kubernetes so kubernetes NFS the bottom line
it went and if it says it gives you a
mountain is what it's kind of like you have
the same the effect is that you have a
directory that is on all of your computer's
that's the same it's like having a hard
drive that's falling at work hard right
right network-attached storage is less than
different terms related to networks test or
strictly speaking is is any storage provider
that's connected to the network and it would
have been a lot faster so the latency for us
is exercising the disc is a lot less Antonio
and and it's it's it's you know it's been
raised a puppy to tell me one other to
remind me as we've been going through this
that there are much more performance
solutions than NFS benefits Jermaine's the
king of kubernetes attached storage because
because its ability to link you know to have
the same storage available to
would you be able to everything in the
entire career is cluster or any cluster for
that matter doesn't have to be covered and
he's using her except in production for a
couple of years of the play with long hair
Longhorn Network find a lot of people are
are there
are using looking stuff at with an f s or
are you doing it without the NFS abstraction
so let's go back to the beginner being her
people who may be asking question what the
hell is this thing this is just a way to
effectively plug the same storage directory
so that the same directory exists on all of
your machines
what exactly the same stuff in it so if
you've ever been in University and you've
done you don't need it again so you know
it's it's it's interesting because I mean
LVL Bee Gees been helping us a lot with
storage in kubernetes and there are much
more otter modern storage classes
Alternatives but knowing NFS is still a
really key important one because it is it is
the really ancient protocol for attaching
storage to the network just our sink all the
things that are sync uses SSH and other
methods of like synchronizing files across
multiple hard drives which is another option
it's an alternative to something like this
and if acid has gotten in a black eye
because of its insecurity even the old days
and now it's got a black eye because it's
really freaking slow and it doesn't tie into
identity management is he is as easily as
some of the newer options I haven't played
with those so I can't really speak to it but
but that's what I
hearing as everybody says and other options
for network-attached storage like rook and
stuff and and Longhorn tools that usually
comes up in those things those are all just
more efficient ways of attaching storage
from a network to a computer and making it
available to all the computers one of the
things that I misunderstood when we got into
this debate a couple weeks back a week back
is when everybody says and if this is slow
compared to the other thing I assumed there
were other directly attached storage
providers that did not use the network they
used you know ice cuzzy your schedule or
something like that and dumb those are also
opposition has lots of lots of ways to
connect you know effectively someplace a
disk drive to a bunch of computers and
that's what an FS is it says this is a
filesystem right and if a strictly speaking
is the file also includes the file
send that goes on top of the sort just
plugging a disk into the computer just gives
you a bunch of ones and zeroes that are on a
piece of hardware and you have to turn that
block storage into something useful by
putting a file system on top of it or any
number you know if your database you can use
to watch storage directly so you know that
can get confusing people will yell at me all
the time saying it that's just block storage
it's not a file system it's really easy to
confuse the two volume and a file system are
different a volume is just a bunch of ones
and zeroes that you can get to that have
that may or may not have an upper hand limit
and may or may not be on on you know what
physical disk or it may be provided by the
cloud at some place at some point there is
you know Hardware that is providing it if
you can if you go far enough you'll find the
hardware this providing a bit that
abstraction is sometimes hidden from you and
that's why she wasn't getting into this is
because sometimes you have to act like an
animal
a place like that it's as if you have
infinite storage is an infinite number of
ones and zeroes in that volume that you can
go to and you can reallocate & Shop up into
different files systems or or make into
database block storage do you know access
there's just a bunch of ways of a look at
you never do that with the database by the
way because the latency of going across the
network is usually pretty evident that
usually that then the timing for that kind
of thing needs to be like directly attached
lease to my date did you whenever you know
the speeds of communicating over the over
the Internet over the network as opposed to
the connecting directly to the bus of the
hardware computer were prohibitive but
that's changing this is two speeds are so
fast now that that whole realm of stuff is
changing and all the all the cloud-related
storage and I'm hearing about these days
being a beginner still again is is
is is Network related so it might not be an
FS but it's it's using IP packets in other
words is traveling over ethernet to get to
where it needs to be so the application
communicates at some level with the this
thing that's keeping track of the storage
through the through the IP ethernet which is
usually ethernet ethernet so hard when they
were but through it through our people say I
pee and that means that it's the same you no
way that their networks and so he can kind
of think of it as having your storage
connected really quickly to a really really
high high speed internet connection that
only you have access to let me know if
you're thinking in Lay terms like then that
might be the way to think of it you can
imagine it being you know it it's not but
imagine if you you took a hard drive and you
plopped it on your own
work and now all your computers can access
that that hard drive at the same time that's
what that's what NFS gives you effectively
you know that that's a visualization is
going to be sympathetic people than to come
the right can I get a we no speak up right
about now and say well that's not exactly
what it is and it's this and that but
effectively you can think of it is you
brought back a lot of routers have this
there are some Riders you can plug a USB
hard drive terabyte hard drive into your
router at home so he might have one of these
and you plug it into that at home and then
everybody on your net working out access
that that story that's not probably manifest
but that's the code was gone
network-attached storage so you know when
you have a shared storage across multiple
devices that are all the connecting to it
through the network that's or talking about
that's network-attached storage it can be
hard where I could be something much bigger
than that
on your. Fast machine we can run price of a
ship day that data and so one place to
update data and every other machine can read
it yeah you do you have to be careful
because there it is being read over the
network so it really depends on how fast
your network is right and this is a thing
that you would never allocate as towards
block from network attached storage to a
most databases because they need really
really really fast access to the sort of it
but that's really old school database is
modern databases or using cashing services
Ram database front ends can she be right as
the stuff and then they're there eventually
sending that data to some sort of you know
at rest storage that's on it's backed up and
on disc someplace and so yeah yeah Direct
Connect fibre connectivity yeah yeah and so
I mean if I were channel is so fast
yeah Enterprise Series 5 vs. yeah it's basic
it is not working so but yeah it's it's so
fast that you know it used to be that that
was a thing it's really not now and it's
very clean Enterprise the rates of network
connectivity are as fast or faster than the
rates for accessing a hard drive in the old
days that was on the same machine and so the
guy I think the lines I think it's fair to
say the lines are I'm really being blurred
between you know Network and device access
right so now that the speeds of the network
are getting on par with like you no buses
speeds of the dino PCI bus connected devices
right into the computer the speeds are there
kind of early with like he was B3 and things
and the others so all of the speeds and
latency issues are really changing and
that's allowing and more and frankly I think
that's what's giving
New Life to NFS because it's one of the
oldest methods of connecting storage and now
if the Network's little bit faster it makes
up for NFS Most of NFS has problems which is
you know mostly speaked over the network
that's the reason we didn't use NFS before
we would use it at the University to share
you know one hard drive for like 20 students
right but a hundred students or whatever but
we knew that it was going to take forever
and if you wanted to do something fast with
it you would copy it off of that network
drive and you would put it onto your hard
drive and then you would use it out from the
hard drive into the 90s right and you would
use it it would use it that way you could
edit your paper that way and then when you
wanted a backup you would copy it into your
shared drive that would send it over the
network and you sit there and wait
and you sit there and wait for the file to
copyright you drag it you drag you over into
the other and it would take forever for it
to read most of you've had experience with
it it's more about latency than throughput
yeah
yeah I think I think I think that's what I
was talking about was late so you write did
I say it wrong but so yeah there is there's
a certain amount of and then there's the
whole problem of concurrent access so some
applications need to lock a file and there's
things like a flock in may be careful those
anyway because even if you're on the same
system that's you know locking files is
really problematic and eunuchs and always
has been is what are you asking for Windows
is is had an interesting Advantage Windows
the windows OS in file system today and you
cannot have two files open at the same time
it's impossible and at least from my
experience and butt butt in Unix you can for
better or worse than you're getting forcing
it so that you have Atomic access to a
certain smile is always been more
challenging the eunuchs world and there's
lots of ways around it but none of the
methods the modern Methods at least the ones
I used to use to add to ensure current
access to net worth
batch file storage apply when you start
using a fast because there's no such thing
commands like a flock and things like that
do not work at all on network attached
storage but there's no warning about it so
these are these are all carry outs for
applications development when when dealing
with stuff directly over Network a storage
but none of them really important anymore
because that stuff is all been sort of
abstract away from you and you just you just
you have a machine and you have a file and
you can use the file and you're good to go
so that's why I want to test and chest and
I'll eventually I want to be like in my own
personal cluster I definitely going to use
the rook and stuff and things like that
because they're faster protocols and we're
modern protocols but they're still Network
protocols at the end of the day right there
disc Access Network protocols as they say
that right that's what they are missing a
protocol sound like HTTP which is an
application layer
but we're talking about a lot lower level
protocol and if you don't don't know
networking stack stuff you might want to
review that she's sharp Fritz has a
frustrating session trying to set up ravendb
hours later finds a little note in the dogs
that says raven TV doesn't support NFS
princess so that's exactly why I'm so happy
you said that I've been done for C sharp for
it so you know and that's another great
screamer but that's exactly what I'm talking
about you know NFS is is is roasted you know
a lot of stuff out the window without
telling you and if you think of NFS if you
think of storage over in the Fest as the
same as this mounted storage you know know
you'll get you'll get in trouble because it
has a lot of a lot of other things it
doesn't do currency it doesn't do you know
it has a higher latency excetera excetera
you know those are those are issues in and
if you can get around them there's a lot of
ways to get around them for example Alaska
search I know uses Network uses a host past
Thornton actually think of the right they
could be ready I don't want to get too deep
into the woods on the community stuff but
there are other storage classes that you can
use in kubernetes that allow you to use the
hardware storage of the node the Pod is
running on and that's a very, very specific
lingo their butt and and then those cases a
stateful set which is absolute godsend in
the communities world and can't you know
what this gets back to the thing we talked
about yesterday about designing applications
in architecting them with regard to you know
Cloud Affinity because if you if you try to
create the same sort of applications
no do you have to know how to divide them up
and stuff because you're going to have to
have applications that can run concurrently
on multiple instances multiple pod replicas
and each one is going to have you in a few
Staples at each one is going to have its own
State on its own hard drive on its own node
that is always going to request again and
unless that Noah goes away and if that never
goes away what happens where's your
redundancy where is your back up and I'll
step in those all affect how you design a
thing because you have to be able to until
you and it's it's complicated it's
complicated
don't forget it as great as great fur and
long terms for you know for sustainability
and keeping stuff up and and you know stuff
to go down and you can be fine because the
other one still there and they know how but
you have the architect of that way when
you're developing your applications you
can't just say I'm going to make this
database it's going to run on this one big
ass you know block of storage on this local
hard drive that those days are gone and if
you if you create applications that that are
locked into that architecture they cannot in
that state easily be poured it over to
kubernetes in the cloud a living on Primus
suck because and that's why we see such a
plethora of newly emerging database cashing
service right it's got to be like that
because because because the old model just
doesn't work anymore I never did work by the
way
I mean that's why people got into like
database charting and all that stuff because
they had to have redundancy and there was
none of his friends he was like a single
point of failure and then you hope your hard
drive for good on that one thing and then
you use Canyon Del Rey 5 on the hard drive
that was supporting our database those are
the old days and and you didn't put anything
on NFS except for like students you know
documents and shit like that that didn't
have any latency demands at all so it's a
pretty interesting world that we live in but
NFS has been a big piece of this I was super
surprised to hear that NFS was even being
used in 2022 actually 2021 11 a good friend
of mine is very trusted and making gobs and
gobs of money is now we're doing kubernetes
architecture actually said onfs is fine
you'll be great at and what because I mean
last time left in a festive was real and
security would never use it for anything and
and and now I've been convinced that yes and
if it's is fine
back and if this is our primary storage
Methods at work we have thousands of people
using it in kubernetes and that sometimes
have problems so we have a storage cost to
just filled and so this is all that me to to
look into an efficient simplify my goal in
this effort is to set up an FS server it's
why I'm only making one gigabyte or 10 and
then fill the thing I want to blow it up
which is also why I am using vagrant virtual
machines instead of Docker containers or
kind or something because I want to blow it
up on purpose I deliberately want to blow it
up and see what happens let's let's destroy
the cinefest Melt and see what happens to
kubernetes how does it survive that what
does my application do how can I detect that
that's coming how can I know because that's
what happened to Domino we filled in NFS
Mountain the Domino blue the fuck up and
there was no warning it just stopped working
and we had to have production at its for 2
weeks so that has to stop we have to be able
to
see that and there's a lot of we actually
have network-attached storage which I think
might even supports F but it's like this
really fancy ass and that were Naas solution
Hardware solution but they still use an
offense is the abstraction layer to talk to
the thing even if it has a more efficient
way of doing that so you can never Escape
having to know what NFS is and how to how to
use it how to load it and it's been so long
since I've done it I saw the exports file
the other day and I ain't got a warm feeling
and in my heart it's been so long since I've
seen the exports well which is a way of
doing it at and if that's so so this
exercise is to help you and me and everybody
you set up NFS really quickly can I get a
quick-and-dirty helloworld feel for manifest
does and and then start messing with it
including blowing it up you know what
happens if it's not there or what is
kubernetes do with it when I going to do
crazy stuff with this particular learning
lab but but but this other stuff is going to
be
Fanta to blow up and if it is okay for a
used case but you like they don't want
hundred percent of a structure only agree
SQL database on an offense is a heavy loads
in with that idea I absolutely and if it's
that obvious choice for a stream of high
school yeah yeah you would never want to do
that object storage is is better I think
I'll just forward you mean something like
red is sore or ldap or or couch right there
all their different but but yeah that's
three stores
yeah how late is f i mean storage
we need I need to categorize all my storage
Solutions in my head at some point I need to
say I was going to say yeah but when you say
I'm kind of things are you
the object relational
relational model stuff like like it was a go
Orange from that rails me popular that's not
what you're talking about is something
definitely different when you say object
storage and get pulled over ACP okay maybe
it is then
yeah yeah I'm thinking about
yeah when I went to write whatever is or the
term object with regard to storage I always
think of the object request orb or repressed
broker kind of stuff Corbin
hey I know it's not a thing anymore I was
going to say I just have to make sure that's
not weird because it mean I thought when I
heard our PC grpc I was like oh shit or PCS
back
where's the xml-rpc and I know it's actually
works against you being around the block
away at the other people use the name they
recycle the names they recycle the names of
things and forget the a recipe yeah that's
obvious or yeah that's pretty much it it's
basically stuff so that's why I had to ask
because when someone said hey and if that's
his back I was like are you talking about
the same NFS so it's kind of It kind of
works against you if you've been around for
one of these terms in your head that are
getting recycled or a been adapted to
something new and you have to make sure
which version of their meaning which I find
fascinating
irpc by the way is remote procedure called
home and that's the standard grpc is how all
of committees does everything internally and
it's super fast and it's super efficient has
nothing to do with XML and remote procedure
called a general or I think we'll get back
to that yeah he's been here forever it is
two difference of of which version of it are
you talking about right it's it's at the end
of the day that is is a way to store stuff
on all the computers that makes it look like
all the computers have the same hard drive
that's that's what it looks like and we'll
go ahead and try without you know so I
happen to know how to do this already so I'm
just going to jump right in and do I just
wanted to break out this this part from the
other
because this is considered separate from the
everyday stuff no I do want to go look at
the related section from another lab I just
did
I'm still doing actually the kubernetes
local qbdm stuff
so in order to test in order to test covered
Eddie's installation you might want to set
up an offense as a part of it but it's not
necessarily in required
Samurai 7 health machine settings
I think that it's just the one which is what
we were looking at yesterday
communicative cluster how about I captured
it
we got to work on those join already able to
put epoxy and I saw this is why I'm breaking
this peace out
I think this one might be it yeah
I think that might be at when I go check it
oh that's not it I ain't got it to you
not yet I got not yet anyway I got lots of
fun stuff to do before that
and have to be a reason P yeah right
yeah I mix
well that's that that is the first time I
was exposed to object stores was rails
Ruby on Rails uses OmniSource
am I going to be is an object stores
database so that's why I was asking
yeah which Ave is if you're wondering what
we talked about if there's there's two
primary forms of stored as far as I know
object stores with store
store objects you know the properties and
some objects can be different than others
and Aquarium by saying hey give me all the
objects that have these properties even
though some can have like extra properties
and the other one is relational the other
traditional SQL kind of relational databases
that's totally different
yeah I know I said but that was my first
real relationship with objects worth it and
it was a pain in the ass that's the reason
people hate Mongo versus SQL
because I mean there are sometimes and it
makes sense to store things as individual
objects in a store and then there's times
where you want to break up the properties of
those objects in and create relational if
things that's a toy that's that entire topic
needs a conversation somehow and I really
think we need to have like a date of boost
where we talked about data organization and
made modeling thing and that kind of thing
is so important and I don't know where to
fit it I don't know what to get for the
machine settings okay so this is the one
I think this is the one no that's not the
one I thought it was
Olaf yes
yes hola yeah I just used all the time I
said Microsoft thing that's their version of
object storage we used to do that all the
time so I'm asking just like so many
different variations on this I know
yeah grass storage yet there's tons of
different storage Methods at so much for
them to anybody I know and it's like and
then what do we cover right
I don't know I'm just going to keep keep
plugging away here and will do
just what your mom left from Kimmy Security
in today y'all you did nice
that's okay we're just doing that we just
did that in our bigger setup
I'm going to look for it again so
setting up when I search for sitting up NFS
in vagrant and I found like the mother of
all
I feel like the mother of all set up here I
can't remember where I found it
I said that's why I'm kind of concerned
yeah here we go and if a server memory 1 CPU
virtualbox private Network
this is almost exactly what I have
so then you have to add
a separate drive separate volume
Yep this is a good one that's let's save
this one is this
you know what why do they have such a shity
tiles
I don't even know what style is of this
thing
have for an Arch Linux for kubernetes
cluster here's one for Arch Linux if you
want to use it
and I fell asleep this document I don't know
why I there yet they smell wrong or
something
I mean there's a bunch of really great
things I normally not a fan of dead.to stuff
but
I got to learn something here
yeah I mean that's the way it cuz half the
battle is knowing what to learn right
this is doing karate stuff we don't want to
date yet isn't going to Festus me if you're
vagrants
ansible setup in FS
well I have one I just don't know where I
got it now I thought I added it
I thought I added it but I don't remember
VM synced folder and investment options
how do you sync folder before what is that
I don't want to plug in no fucking plugins
you don't need a plug-in forI need a plug-in
for this
you just need versabox driver that I already
know
adding n f s adding
additional hard drive with vagrants
virtualbox driver I want to find this link I
have a really good link. They're adding a
second hard drive
Yep this is the one that's the one I'm going
to get a link to that
everything should be virtual
this is this is the one this is a really
great tutorial some of these things are
probably a phase out over time this is just
notes
so this is this is an old one but it's
really good so the key here is
what is going to do
so yeah I've already done all this so I'm
just going to throw this in there and get it
to work
so this is a little bit he don't know the
other vagrant stuff it kind of got a need
you need to know that so
I don't think I went to call these here
tasks
and I put God first
I'm not using cards no Chi no no you're not
and never Jimmy what are Sonic's production
but first say
so
be able to create a vagrant virtual machines
we already have that
they are Fallas River yet
yep it's like old-school Ruby which is
purely fun cuz I suck I have the guy that
don't remember me at all
American River machines the game this is the
first thing
it's all virtual box
yeah I'm not going to the Oracle virtualbox
cuz it got bought by Oracle
it's learning lab covers setting up
a shared network drive using n f s
exported infs
near me very old but still coming to use
infs protocol
and exporting a single secondary drive on a
control
machine that is mounted remotely
from the from the worker machines so that
all
all machines share the same path
2 to the file system
mounted on that volume
that's what they said right then I sent you
here you should take it
I think it's a great that rule adding more
people should go for that stuff
decentralized spouse's and yeah
is built directly on top of ipfs I think
that already exists, in fact I'm pretty sure
it already exists there's an people talking
about making a new internet based on ipfs a
new web missed a bunch of shared Repose at
least talking about that me too I like that
they're at least talking about that
possibility because that is a decentralized
technology that does not depend on
blockchain
and young people get so tied up and this
whole watching distribution decentralisation
think I might decentralisation is totally
different boxing black chain is one way to
decentralize but it doesn't have to be the
only way in ipfs there's some there's some
possibilities worth exploring with that and
my opinion so anyway I thought about that a
lot I looked at a lot for some sort of an
exchange traded from the station that we
could use but yeah oh yeah they've been to
Florida and I do too I continue to mess them
up I get them wrong all the time I saw they
asked me if my FS work was going to take a
nap but there's and you didn't you tell them
they'll carry on WOW
13 has a dependency ipf it seems ffss
and I heard you can Jose single file type is
so I think you confused with that excite
yeah absolutely that's that's that's I
didn't realize 13 was into that there's been
so many I've heard so many different
definitions to grab 3 is at this point that
it's hard to lock it in any town I'm going
to let that settle down a little bit before
I get into it but
yeah we're going to need something new all
right so so this is all we're doing here all
we're doing is we're making some vagrant
files and actually know how to do this so
cuz I already made one so I'm going to copy
my vagrant file you know what for the sake
for the sake of the learning lab we're going
to start from scratch as if I didn't know
how to do that already and I'm going to the
repetition will help me because I've already
done it and I need to do it again let me try
to do it from scratch okay so here is what
we're working on right
here's the what of this little learning left
and we should probably be done with this one
within an hour or two famous last words
right but it should not take more than an
hour because we we've eliminated a bunch of
the other complications and I said this is a
stepping stone toward another project I'm
working on another learning lab which is
installing kubernetes from scratch with an
FS store with an NFS storage class which I
will continue to be doing late into the
night tonight on this wonderful Friday I'm
so excited I love the weekend cuz it means
I'm free to explore and do all kinds of
great fun stuff and I know what this is
really making me feel good because I really
feel like I'm getting a handle on kubernetes
at the low-level which gives me a feeling of
confidence more than I had it coming into
this from this application site
I like to know how it works it makes me feel
comfortable even if you know I still need to
learn how to do something practical on that
stuff went pretty first impressions of Earth
reading did you find a good one
how to make a dress I'm going to put that in
my list
unicorn T my son's got a quarantine finally
my stepson
what is when three
thank you for that that the links are
everybody feels good and better so far I've
got three sons if I covid
and they seem to be fine cuz I got
vaccinated I think we're going to do this
next
Isis let's follow along in this tutorial
here I think I said my labs are more a
statement of the tasks that need to be
accomplished and then related links to stuff
that talks about how to accomplish that the
gold being hey here's something to
challenge yourself
yeah there is a lot of emotional 13 I wish I
kind of wanted to cook to cool down before
we have a conversation it's just too heated
right now
all right so first of all how do we even use
vagrant right so if Acorn is new to you
so you have to install vagrant and you have
to submerge the box and then you have to
install vagrant and you can do that on Mac
Linux or Windows but I'm doing it on Linux
and NFS is in Lenox thing for the most part
if you're visiting to try this with somebody
as well somebody's answering I got to answer
the door
my dog is sitting in the chair that she not
supposed to sit in cuz my wife is out of the
house she's such a little sneak
am I my Mac from work just came
I have to text my wife this is so funny
having to take a picture
oh and now you're out okay
I got Sam in the chair
she's so funny this dog
your stuff is not really out of blockchain
is controlled by a few big companies there's
no hash or in a few minutes on the clock Jay
only awake so I can be Chase or anything
when I get to Main expires oh God
ouch ouch that's crazy
ranchers for IBM's he's a
craze the Mainframe holyshit
if they bring communities to the Mainframe
that is crazy
that is insane
shit if they do that hey to that
yeah
my God what are you guys talking about I
can't I can't focus cuz you talking about
cool stuff
oh God meme acquisitions
mute notifications from people who have an
entity profile photo
are we going to have one of those Fridays
and we just laugh the whole time I have a
feeling we are
oh God first container escape on a Mainframe
oh my God can you imagine
oh my God I control plane
and unwell this cell phone to get in the
pods and possible and well themselves from
the annoying infrastructure with clear
standards
I'll have to see I think yeah
give me interesting to see I unless it's
really exciting thing the old one I was
saying let me get rid of that
okay so here here we go this is Let's do
let's see if I can make a vagrant file from
scratch right so this is this is supposed to
be covered already by other learning but I'm
going to go ahead and try to do my stuff
here
I'm going to meet a couple expert under the
age of 80 in the world yes
I would like to be outside ipfs then I'd be
cool
can I see all right so how do we do vagran
well and I'm still on the fence I go back
and forth as a love-hate relationship with
vagrant I do want to look at doing all of
this potentially interfering with virtualbox
driver later I've heard people do that I've
heard I've heard people are doing the same
thing I do with vagrant with terraform but
that's not what your phone was designed to
do nor is it what is it was designed to do a
current was designed to create develop an
environmentally quickly however you know I'm
not opposed to doing those others but bigger
than the one I know right now and I'm
learning right now and then I can decide to
change to get off at later but I'm at least
going to beg her to be dangerous so anytime
you start a new big and project if you're
bigger than it and and that'll give you a
vagrant file
and it's this big ugly ass thing if you
don't want a big one like that you can do
vagrant
Annette dash dash minimal
and you can also tell it what kind of os you
want I'm going to be forever using L8 until
someone tells me not to the overwhelming
consensus is Alma it is the best version of
red hat that's not red hat so I'm going to
use generic generic on the 8th
and this will give us a bigger file that
have all the extra shit in it and that is
all we need milk if you just do this by
itself you can do vagrant up and you'll get
a virtual machine
and that is it
I think that's pretty amazing I mean
considering the steps I would have to do
with the graphic tool to just do that
you know I don't mind waiting around for it
to download The Invention do the rest right
quickly because I cleaned out. Maker. D in
my home directory which is sometimes
necessary to get bigger and back happy again
you've been working a lot of projects
simultaneously so just doing a few commands
like that I get a virtual machine that's
that's provision with all the defaults and I
don't know what those two have a peek at it
and see the virtual box driver and I agree
this is another reason to use a verse about
driving instead of live birds with Megan is
not doesn't work very well I tried it I use
the doctor in Virginia at work fine it was
very fast it was a lot faster and
provisioning these systems of stuff but I
don't think it's going to be as mainstream
so I'm going to go ahead and do this with
vagrant a meeting with the other now so I
can actually run virtualbox and you'll see
and you'll see the new one that just made in
fact it has an old one is still there I
already download I thought so so here's the
new one that was just created so NFS vagrant
a default a vagrant local blah blah blah and
it's just so it's here you can look at it
you're not supposed to mess with it here I
kind of want to turn that one off and
deleted because but it's not hurting
anything right now I just was going to stop
at anyway
and I'm going to close it down because it's
taking its taking a gram and should I don't
want that so you can still use virtualbox is
your manager if you want to inspect what it
did right you can look at all this
information for the command line as well but
so here you go it says operating system
right at base memory 20482 processors that's
the default hard disk Optical Boudoir has
all those things video memory
grab your coat it does not make it doesn't
have a graphics controller so as you can see
it's just it's just a terminal because
there's no graphics on it you can actually
add breezly and you can do disabled audio
not working until 7 a.m. network adapter
which has been added which is normal
so that's pretty easy to do right. Just
debts gave us a server pretty quickly and
easily and then you can get crazy with it
you can like add new stuff to it and I don't
even know how to add an extra volume using
the graphic interface that's what we're
going to do so we already know that all of
this all of the basics are fine it's going
to make now it did it did make I kind of
want to make it not to GB so I kind of want
to change it right so let's go ahead and
destroy that one bigger and destroy
and I'm going to make it
so it has I want it on a limited so the way
to do that is to make a virtual machine so
we know we want 3 virtual machines right so
let's go let's start by making three virtual
machines I mean use a trick that I learned
using Ruby
and I got to remember this in taxes so we're
going to give a list you're going to call
and control and call One Work or one
and one or her too so that's going to do
whatever we stay here has and I guess we
could put what's your favorite machine or
node
a butt memes and calling to main gym
and then we're going to do it end here so
now we'll get three of them right but let's
make them so that their names match so let's
say instead of config now we're going to do
VM
BMW M box maybe we should just TV how about
we do a machine
M4 VM it doesn't matter he would know it
whatever
it's 11 a.m. Hostname I think it is
have to go look it up and we can give it an
individual name so he was a dollar sign and
we're going to say I wanted to do whatever I
wait
for each name as am I have this wrong so now
I don't remember ethical cheat and look up
the one I did already cuz I don't remember
either the wrong what you doing
Cuban Eddie's vagrant comedian okay great. I
am
I'm going to cheat so each do name
yeah it is named after all
yeah yeah we have to have two of them
actually two
your name alright so
see you let me do some you do the name for
each name
we're going to config. VM Define that's
whatwhen I missing so we need to define a v
m
for that name all right I got you I got it I
got to get going with this
yeah I was at so that's going to find a name
and and then we're going to say
this has to do as well so also am here
and we have another end now and
say yeah and then down here we can put name
a hostname right
VM. Hostname m node. VM
node. I found a box that again. For me it's
because it's a demain actually
Negron calls them domains
config p.m. to find I wake up and down
and I wish we got hey thanks for the Fall by
The Weeknd Kemar
they call him the means they don't call him
I don't know it's I know what to do here
what what's a good thing to call it
why do they call it here they call him BB's
virtualbox
yeah but this is just for the provider
and here they call an iSCSI Target. VM so
account I mean I've been calling him nodes
I've been calling him know it's
I like the word known as it is from
communities land but I'm going to keep it
that way
got in Plains or machine or whatever
I just use underscore one inside the block
for land of runners Persona box interesting
that's cool so sweet as a host name sis
actually no. VM. Hussein that's what I miss
the first time
and
we need don't need a private Network now
this is something that really caught me
off-guard so let's just try this first of
all let's try to get it so this should make
us three nodes
Mercury 1 or Cat 2 this should make us three
notes
vagrant up this should get us three notes
that I wish you would do this currently but
so far no dice
no dice on that
going to get a couple notes Here I mean we
have to wait but
considering how long do we have to wait if
we didn't have this tool proof have to be
playing around the graphics and stuff I can
actually still make coffee with
and there is a thing called link that that
makes its provisional bit faster
I need to let that out there something like
you can make it so that it just reuses the
one that was already the base it was already
downloaded
so it's booting the machine so there's three
machines booted up
now we didn't set this abuse of this trying
to do to see views into gay around for each
one so my machine is probably going to be
going to be hurting
yeah let's see how much my machine is
hurting
oh this is not big enough so I have to do
this one is dead
but it's friends then we go CVS
is it which one is it was just the top thing
that shows you all that individual CPUs I
can't I can't remember
yeah I do that too
omap 122 so then it gives you the actual
thing oh wow that's so cool
that's really really cool and so you can set
the how many accounts
icicle mono affected user play Tel Aviv
Forestview
I don't think that's the one
she's the one that shows all the CPUs you
can't remember there's there's a key that
will show you all the CPUs
I can't remember it's not one of the
standard ones toggle summary
tasks if you stay slowed average memory cm
oh t
and I don't think his memory another one
I'm so from is it this top is is inhibited
because it's not enough space
if I zoom in and it'll do it I will show all
the course
I guess because of the singing to herself so
we have
maybe they're not too busy
Shirley Mass but much more readable oh God
no kidding me she is not readable and no it
isn't I strongly disagree with that that's a
personal preference obviously but God now
give me imagine any day
so
I need it for example it's not him
completely in tune of what this is right
obviously this is whatever the value is that
gets used to route
so so yeah yeah
all right let's go back
I can make a fox okay so we have a vagrant
status and this will show us the machines
that are up
we can actually do vagrant
SSH into each one of them could do that for
a lube for Ian control worker
control worker do
vagrant s h i n n s e l s CPU
I grabbed I CPUs
I think you can isolate it a better way than
that so we can actually go look at all of
them
I found UPS / 2
so they all have two CPUs
and I wonder what their host names are at
let's see what their host names are showing
I want to make sure the hosts names got
changed control worker one or two so those
look at created and machines if you just
want to make her into that you have to
remember all the names or anything it keeps
Carol the DNS everything for you if you want
to do that which I like I appreciate that
that's for useful and then you can like do
your install
so so those are fully running
and that that works just fine
so they gave us three machines now if we we
want it known in on
hone in on the CPU and stuff we actually
have to provide another subsets we have to
say
it's config for Vidor I want to see a
provider
live no virtualbox in this only happens if
the provider is virtualbox
do I can ever do that Bebe
and in this you have to do your your CPU and
stuff inside of here so that we can save e
b. CPUs who's won
babies. Meme
equals equals to K if you want to 1024
I know that's enough to run it but one
I mean it'll be interesting to see if you
can even do it we really just doing it a DNS
tester it's let me see if I got that right
so
1024 memory
animated is a string and not a number I
think that's interesting I think it'll get
done anyway that's how we're going to mount
the volume but not right now so we have
memory and CPU is going to be too but I
suspect he's fine I just want to see if we
can actually admit it
now if we try to do a vagrant reload
provision this does not
this does not do the things oh
she wants is a memory alright memory
provision
so it is actually shutting the VM down and
restarting an interesting I wonder if this
is It's a Reload is generally faster I think
it's because it doesn't Force to reload of
the base OSI think the other one forces a
real of the base of us every time we going
to find out though
so that's just as offer control is working
and working now
now I can be working hours to it seems it's
already seems faster or so
I'm curious to see if it's if it can
reprovision and the number expert Collision
on 22
I mean that kind of stuff is nice for
Collision fixing and stuff and that's not
something ansible would probably do I'm
guessing
yeah I can meet you miss a call I meet this
tool is designed for exactly what we're
using it for vagrant if it's an old tool
and so far it's been working I got kind of
upset with the volume management yesterday
but that was just cuz I didn't understand
that we were going to no matter what we were
still going to have to use a provider to do
the virtual machine I mean that they did
this conditions now that we got that worked
out I'm good
let's try let's see if this changed the size
of the stuff
I see what happened to see if used so now we
have one seat for you
and memory should be a lot smaller as well
so yep quite a bit less now swap is still on
but we don't care
not for this particular case
that's definitely one Mega 1024k
Citra scene of Oak is it took to away for
the swap to turn swap off now if you want to
we can put that in the provision section
and that's I don't know what what's this
within a readme
if not then okay current Terrace
disable swap on all machines
so instituted to do something like that you
have to put it in the provision section so
when you do that
I'm going to do that
bigger and file so we're going to do when
add a provision so
is it p.m. no. Provision
and then there's a bunch of provision types
how's it going man there's a bunch of
information types we're going to be doing
the
shell type I don't remember the syntax I'm
trying to remember it and then there is a
file
that you can type I can't remember it I'm
going to look it up
and practice University PS thanks for that
Frank when I try that really quick over here
access to that I have to refresh my memory
on that I don't know it
so and Brock
let's try that one so one frog hump Rock and
one thank you for that that's fantastic I'm
going to actually add a note so I don't
forget it
use in frock
for number of CPUs
I just learned about in frock which is just
the number of CPUs
as opposed to LS CPU
which gives much more information
thank you cuz I will forget that so had to
make a note thank you Frank for looking that
up alright so
I don't remember this Linus's I got to
memorize this so so config VM provision
and this case is going to be VM I don't want
that this provision
see here's the thing you can have it be a
config provision and it will still run and
everything or we can put it inside of this
of the of the VM I'm pretty sure a scope and
then it just makes more sense if it's there
shall pass and then it will run that past
and you keep going if you want so I'm going
to do this
not that one
and I I am starting to have a preference
here my my preference is
to not node
VM my preference is to
it's too pretty in a separate file because I
didn't answer the shell script right I don't
like having shell in my vague in my Ruby
path and I called provision why the fuck
would you put attention you don't need it
keep color equals true why not I want my own
cars
I didn't know about that until tell that so
by adding that now it'll run my provision
script right
and
I can run Ben bash cuz he's got bash on them
and it will run this on everyone right so I
wanted to see Abel swap so sue to swap
and there's a sedline you have to do to do
this
which I know about cuz I have it I have to
put this in a in a thing as well set find
bash script to disable DNS no
disabled swap online X
so it's pseudo slop off
and what else kids
they aren't services vagrants
provision swap
there is disabled from FS time
yeah which is pretty Tacony and measure but
yeah
I thought that's a that's on everything
need to disable it on the current running
system
and disable the swap partition for the next
Foods in and see if estab
the sibling swap for kubernetes is not
required anymore but the older communities
still says to do it and supports it so I'm
going to do that
Dash a
sudu knows it is as soon as you said yeah
you do
said that I which is an In-Place edit of a
file a man, this rather than make a mistake
so this is replacing swap with a single
character boundary with
oh wait no it's not the first one is a match
it says if it matches this then do this so
if the line contains the word swapping it
anywhere then replace the first character
the first position which is not a character
with a with a comment so that's that's how
you comment something out using said
learn Excel so what we can do now is we can
actually reprovision
vagrant reload dash dash for vision and it
will add it will run my provision script and
it should disable swap
for each one and you it tells you over here
when it's doing the provisioning to
goal here is to get in it for working and if
it's working but some of these other things
I just wanted to get them all the pieces
here
Honeypot challenges posed to the first part
of the documentary about coronavirus
oh yeah they're the ones who did the whole
thing on and you grab key well and
everything right
and that's fantastic I did not know that bud
the Bandit oh I have to go I have to go get
that that would be a great thing to watch I
can I want to watch it while we're
are we doing this weekend kind of put it if
you put it in the corner I could do that
right can we watch it
I mean if I hear the sound is for the odds
of getting kept off so
I kind of want to I kind of want to watch it
and comment on it while we're going through
it though I'ma have to watch it later
tonight like I just get the popcorn or
something
alright so let's see what happened with swap
swap how can we even list the swap
I can release the swap how can I check if
swap is disabled
I know an easy way to do that
I just want to check to see that it is
disabled swap on show and we go well that
was easy
swap on
or gigs so I do have swap on here swap swap
then to check if it was disabled
all right so you are our list show me
k
I don't mean that either
alright so
let's do a swap on that shot show
that would be a no I'm guessing
I guess that means there's no swap I don't
know
fake friends the top without
I know you can do top and have it spent
something out doesn't freeze and show it
doesn't
Alfredo stroessner of course it says yes ha
there is no Swap all right so
I feel like we're making progress okay now
becomes the volume now in the volume stuff
there is just a thank you for the fall the
volume stuff you just can't get around them
things you have to memorize hear the case so
the one thing about this that I really want
to get hit hard on I was like where does
this come from right
so these things are sub commands of VB
veeam box manage whatever and that's
actually
what do you mean it don't need that to get
an FS all I know I don't
Shape Up is an immensely people by saying
that I did I just wanted to do it anyway
but that Doc and discs
I tried this way and it didn't work so if
you know a way to fix it let's do it
yeah they got this this distant not work for
me
they are in this configuration
I tried it this way and it wouldn't do it I
don't know how many times I try to
if you had the exact line
no I didn't have that that's like the one
thing I didn't do do you have to do that in
order to turn it on
that would be so much better
that is the one thing I fucking didn't do
and it blew like 2 hours on it and you save
me time again or near VIP status as always
you got to be kidding me that was the only
thing I know I did I handle this disk usage
sit in there and I was expecting to see a
volume in there and then I couldn't see the
volume and I was pissed I was pissed because
I did all this but I didn't read this I
didn't read this
I didn't read that I had all of this in
there I had this every night all of this in
there and didn't work
and I was like what the hell God damn if
that's true
how long is this beenhow long is this been
an experimental that's what I want to know
is it been experimental 4eva or is it like
it's been wonderful I give you turned on you
doing this is your own rescue currently has
not officially supported
how how much more risky is this than using
the the calls directly to the provider at
cuz if they if they change the provider I
think that would be more risky
you know what I mean I I think I think the
risk is
acceptable and you're my favorite person
today again I cannot believe
yeah cuz it was it made me sick to my
stomach right
seriously it made me sick to my stomach
adding all the specific driver stuff to my
vagrant file but then I thought to myself
well I already I'm already putting a section
in there that says this section is for this
provider
I just happened to be a lot simpler right is
it
I still I still going to go into the VM
section you like will see him in with memory
right I imagine that's like so cool good
Emmett
yeah yeah I'm going to try that
yeah internally that's what I say and I
don't know but I don't want to have to
remember all that that's all I was
complaining so I haven't yesterday saying
hey the whole point of a corn is abstract
that shit away from this otherwise why don't
I just make a shell script that calls via
met box manage directly
which is what it is say so I guess everyone
wants to know what time I'm going off here
that's what this is this year all of this
stuff is exactly it directly what you can do
by calling vbv box manager d-box manage if
you pass device manager you do all of that
from the command line it will do the same
thing
it will do the same thing
so so this is just a thing on top of that so
to hear that there is a disc underneath
there makes me very happy actually and I
actually had that in my original things and
it wasn't working and I was like why isn't
this working and now I know I got a message
that kind of pisses me off it does
alright so
what are baby boxing Haven we are sitting
right now I'm just sitting up in the Fest
Mount so I can fill it and break it and see
what happens and I set up coronavirus losing
qpdm from fragrant before so what I meant to
say blah
yep ask our provider and it is
doesn't this have to be underneath the
provider this is another thing to
see how I just defines a provider here
this is a 60 yd box because I tried the
whole thing with you Boo and leave Levert
and it works fine but in this case we have
problems because of campaign external
volumes as usually
yeah this is a resize weeks is primary
trivia I think I look at this this is
exactly what I did the question I have that
was descent need to go within a few bucks
provider or not and I am going to say yes
you know what it is exactly what I had is
exactly what I had so if I hear another
thing I want to try so if you do for
somebody like that can you just do can you
do know to DMC bees memory you can think you
can it still has to be here it's still has
to be here right
yeah I retired I saw the example with extra
discs I actually saw that you just have to
give it a name it's all I have to do today
so I think I'm trying to decide if I should
put the disk line here inside the rental box
thing cuz I need everything for your memory
there's no way around that and I don't know
why you have to have a provider for
Starbucks up here
I think I can get aroundI think I can get
around it by doing this I think I can just
put a DVD disc in
I think I think I think yeah I think I can
do that is to be M. Disc
yeah I had two eggs this exact line for
I'm so frustrated disc is a discs disc disc
and then
wait did it say discusses a plural
yeah I can put a name on it is extra that's
I read that line exactly yesterday so so is
this storage going to give it 10 GB for
primary and then the other ones so we do
name equals
extra are for any faster something right
when I give that I'm going to get that 10 MB
can I hope this works
reload the thing
that's so cool alright so fragrance
I can't reload oh please use caution
there are urgent cares about please fix
as afraid of this yeah you have to put the
dis stuff outside here
and you have to do this other thing
I think you start to put in provider outside
to I don't know I try
if I'm being audited timer 13
are we
yeah thank you I don't think we have to put
the provider thing up there I hope we don't
this is looking good so far so good I can't
believe
River was missing the whole time it's always
something like that
now here's the part when somebody says read
the doc's tassel it was there the whole time
I was so focused on this section that I
totally missed this
I totally miss this I was so focused on the
section I didn't read the beginning I like
skin right over it
and you know I had it all right I had to
send text right I read this I remember
saying Hey I want to do 3. I was like so
excited and I couldn't get any of that shit
to work and I followed it for like an hour
or two hours and it turns out to be it is
Jupiter is pretty cool you up and then we
got to this bigger an experimental stuff
Juventus it's a shame that's insane
it was just this missing fucking I need to
make a thing about this and you say don't
forget very experimental
alright so let's do our run on all thing
let's do lsblk
there we go stb's oh my God
all I got what makes me so angry
is so much easier that was so much easier
don't
don't be be be be coming come in and come on
in here and learn how to not be me
happy me like to read the doc's I mean
seriously
it's I want it small cuz I'm going to fill
it up
the reason I wanted Smalls going to pull the
shit out of it by filling it up as an
investment and I want to see all the
warnings and I'm going to report those in
kubernetes that's why I wanted to do this
this a whole point of using a VM he is it I
want to blow the shit out of a volume that's
under that's backing of virtual that's
backing in NFS amount and then I want to see
what happens
I do glance over documentation a lot because
I'm trying to get to the actual thing that
just gets me what I need I don't necessarily
want to go get exhaustive into the
documentation I want to get what I need for
the moment and then I can Circle back and do
an exhaustive if I if I spent all the time
reading every single word on the vagrant
documentation I would be reading for like a
full day I still need to do that and I want
to do that but I would rather the others
argument like you know at what point do you
lose more time making mistakes like I just
made if I just read the whole doc from
beginning to end but I just don't know the
other thing to do is I don't trust
documentation I have read so much
documentation is absolute bullshit that the
official it's official documentation and the
best way for me to do is to use the code
we haven't saved your hours are pulling
sometimes but not always
I have spent hours of hair pulling because I
read the dogs and and then when I went to
the code and I looked at the code that saved
me more time to flee with him charts with
Helm charts oh my God
Olympia irrelevant stuff that that to yah
it's theirs it's both of them are problems
yeah it just depends are full of mistakes
it's chock-full of shit that's totally wrong
and unnecessary and you know I can document
that or I can like look at the source code
and see how it works and so that's not that
is a horrible thing that I do it's horrible
think you need to kind of do both right you
need to be able to just sit the fence
between the two of those things if you want
to be yah yah God. You know it's it's it's
the few really horrible bad projects that
I've lost so far bigger and has been really
well documented
it has it's been really well documented so
so I've gone through that that way in and
found out that way in HD
storage safe trolls so this is completely
irrelevant you don't need to do this at all
and I actually want to put this in here and
it put a big old warning in here
warning there is the old a way of adding
disks and the new
experimental way
that is much easier
make sure you know the difference
and don't forget 2 x 4's
if you think the new way
all right
at least once all I don't do that I don't do
that because I don't have time to do that
no it's the part of Justin Time learning you
can't you can't you can't
no you need to get to the to the thing where
you can be productive and then you can come
back and read it at your luxury
so what was the Bell faster right this
Yep this visit may may be broken and may
break
what is this song alright so
and a shity tiles again
alright so good stuff here
it said just had to throw myself at it and
see what sticks
yeah and you know I agree it's it's often
better to go through the whole dogs and that
was that was what got me my that's why I'm
not disagreeing with you that's exactly how
I recommend people do with Bosch
all of the great stuff of Bosch has I've
never once read it and any book or tutorial
or anything like that you have to read a
particular brand expansion forever expansion
is not covered anywhere I have never seen a
book or tutorial or anything covered you
know what covers in the best man page and
the only reason I learned it is because I
went through the Batman page top to bottom
and I learned a ton of extra stuff that was
a complete Dash C Capital C that's another
thing I learned so I'm a total fan of going
through the exhaust of documentation when
you can and you have the time to do that and
it definitely its you know your sister
crapshoot whether you're going to save time
by reading all the docks are going to save
time by fucking around with something so I
figured out
another problem to in the in the technology
world is is finding docs for it in the first
place that are accurate one of the worst
case is that is people that are searching
Internet for ways to do things and parts
things and then get set in Ocotillo and all
the shit that's just absolutely wrong and
the inefficient and all kinds of shit and
they are going to find the wrong answers so
it might case I found the wrong answer which
was the right answer Once Upon a Time right
because it's all data I thank God I got my
own system of note so that I can go update
that and and see what's up so
alright I may go clean get get all cleaned
up here I should have not latest
documentation even retain vitamin E and
developers are really bad
an
it is not somebody I can see that you're
taking this so beautiful thank you for this
small so can fill
I want to do that on purpose so
yeah I like totally happy with I pack we're
done we just need to do the NFL come out
we're done
actually no let's do this let's say
make it so that
Creighton MB secondary volume and not the
expert as an NFS volume and we can put this
on the control machine only
all right so we're going to do that
and I learned a review for this I remembered
the review for this I can't believe I once
knew this I can't remember shit so this
thing here
is only so if the name equals
troll I'll do this one
else I wait we have for everything
and so we only want to add that on the
control box I could have made that a
separate thing but that'll work
hey Grinch vision
do do
dudududu dudududu
oh my God
I had to do
oh yeah alright so let's go check it out
now we should only have bills be on one
crab stb
Oh They'll have it still
they'll have it why do they all have it
probably because I have to do a destroy to
get rid of them
yeah I didn't do a full provision
if the name equals control then make yeah
cuz I already had it
oh I was watching I was watching help me
hammer in another window
yeah I have to I have to mute it though
because reasons
I guess it's against the OS for me to watch
somebody else's while we're watching stuff
but I sometimes watch another streamer while
we're doing stuff
what else we got let's go see I may have to
do a full destroy here
destroy
he's talking about how the game was talking
about the Circadian rhythm and working out
during
and this depression effects of alcohol
I'll stuff and I'm very familiar with
I only has had to ask you to say probably
destroy a I figured I would be I would make
no sense if it actually destroy the disc I
would be super dangerous to write yeah I
would I would be really really surprised and
shocked but they're going to try it with a
try
and my router is gone oh you don't like that
one
I could almost hurt a lot I can always try
cuz he's just talkin
I mean we can kind of listened
I kind of like this
what am I going to do
I'm not a drunk I'll call Hertz to my head
too much for me to ever be addicted to it
all right it's right now
and now we don't have any stb on anyting
every to have it on anything
I meant maybe my crap is wrong fuck
all right enough of that
is interesting but that if stink all right
so
this is however very fast Eddie
this should totally have worked but did not
work
I don't know why that didn't work
why didn't that work we have this should
have matched
and it should only have been executed on
this say this is the only thing I added is
that if statement it's only added
I get too sensitive didn't it didn't work at
all
I don't know I can be wrong vagrants
destroy control
alright vagrants up control Birchbox
that if Sam is not matching for some reason
I don't know why
and because I did too late in the game now
because it was doing it before when it was
there
praying for your shell
nothing
find a recipe I I think it's going to be
interesting I'm not interested in it right
now though because I don't have any use for
it future yeah but I'm in I'm in the now I'm
in the employable now and I got shit to do
it's there's no jobs in Risk by right now
and that there are there like really tiny
esoteric jobs
this if statement is missing for some reason
I don't lie
I haven't working in another one so that's
what I'm confused bylive kickz vagrant
Mega file
that's having an affair then if name equals
control vcpus 2
and this how it works so
what's wrong with this one if name equals
control is it because is because of the
scope is different
I mean if I come in the side doors at work
I think it might actually
yes I need iron. Coffee coffee
he's got better Ruby skills
who's the set up my Mac for work it just
came today too
no I said I'm going to have it be okay now
what none of them do
I sent a bug there's definitely a bug
there is definite mall at bug
this is exactly the same code okay this is
making me
you know what you're brilliant well yeah
that has got to be it I I don't even have to
look
because this Ruby code was was beautiful is
perfect
and we just checked it because it didn't
even rain when it was taken out
and I'm using a different terminal and my
battery is be said for that reason I'm going
to just wait no never hit that problem again
I'm sure that's the reason I don't even have
to look
that's obviously it
yes that's going to bite me in the ass all
the fucking time and I have got to remember
so if that's definitely a thank you for
catching it
what's the exact bash shell
Chipmunks in now all the sub shells will
have it
that was definitely it had all you had to do
is look at it is one of those things where
you like have somebody I can your coding and
you like cannot think of something and you
just need some fresh pair of eyes to look at
them really fucking obvious things I can't
believe I can't believe that was it
yep there it is so so that was it
survey Grant
vagrant reload dash dash provision
it should actually Adam now because they
were at a l there you go there's your first
indication okay make a note of this if you
do not see the big warning then your
environment is fucked up
yeah yeah yeah and you just type the same
thing I just said so yeah
with a Labrador mascot you should Bob
yesLabradors
Grace will shut down
who else is on who else is on Twitch right
now
oh TJ's on mystery of em himself
he's doing little Auto commands
b o r l s p okay I'll be fixed I don't even
have to look at it I already I already know
it's going to be working
yeah see that I'll be out there just to be
no stb and there's an SUV the end
this is Carson how do I turn off the
experimental lab morning just in case
all right so now we just have to do the NFS
amount but I want coffee so I'm going to
stand up and go do that but this is been a
mean this has been a good review of how to
use vagrant we we discovered the the discs
way to use it
is asymptomatic shedding a second drive with
making Roku box I have to edit this because
this is now wrong
hey how's it going go to rush
coming into source code yeah that's a that's
a that's a good idea to
absolutely
I think I have this already
all right
the easiest why is also
experimental
first exports
then and the following
actually we can do a link we can link lab on
this said blank
vagrant
when's / Mega file
so
I swear this whole thing in there
I mean I put it in the lab but I also want
to put a hair cuz this is I don't want to
miss this later
Ruby
and this needs to be
yep
all right I mean there you go again
you know why this wasn't working yesterday
because the documentation said
this only works if virtualbox just interpret
lumbered but I didn't read that
there's so many assumptions about vagrant
using virtualbox at this point that it's
kind of pointless to use Levert or hyper-v
or any of the others
so yeah
this is going to directly impact my
recommendations about virtual machine
software General welcome Louis by the way
full of Davis Lewis because because here's
the thing if
the bickering is one of the most important
tools for developers to use that they are if
they're going to be doing perusing like this
I mean it's about something else like that
there are a lot of virtual there a lot of
virtualization options on Mac or Windows and
stuff like that but those options
AR
they they are limiting two different things
you might want to do later
and based on knowing what most people are
going to want to do later
it's very clear that your virtualization
platform should be Herschel box. Not even
double yourself
windows and you can get the two to work
together I know but it's
it's very very clear I mean the only
virtualbox on that when I want to know and
when do they need to test is before I give
another machine back we have to we have to
test whether you can run virtualbox and
Docker desktop
on Windows me modern Windows machine at the
same time and I think we might have some
problems at one point you couldn't do that
because every one of them blocks down do I
provide even a Lennox if one thing is
locking down the hypervisor you can't have
the thing can't live birds and versus box
spring at the same time they don't allow it
I don't know how it they they both one of
them on lockdown then the internal I have
imagined something like that and just looks
so if you have to pick one virtualization
technology for your workstation as a
beginner or as a veteran you have to make
some important decisions about what is it
going to end table by having so I'm going to
give you a couple examples of that so many
Cube requires a driver by the fault that we
use Docker but it can use virtualbox I can
use for free I can use other stuff like that
could you allowed to know a secret probably
but that's definitely not a beginner thing
and that's that's that's why I keep coming
back to you like a lot of these things are
learning immediately thinking about where is
this going to go in the Boost series 4 skill
stack how am I going to introduce
virtualization to an absolute beginner first
of all I I know that I'm going to be
introducing Docker but way before we entered
his fertilization we won't be doing
virtualization at all until the
infrastructure engineering boost at which
time we'll start talking about you know
things like that even though using
virtualbox has relevance obviously outside
of that for developers which is what vagran
is about I'm using vagrant more as an
operational you know tool to like lay out
network engineering community stuff
yeah
when you're using kiwi the other day are
using it with let I was living with him who
so this is something I finally feel like I
understand now I have a write-up on this
let me show you
so I spent a great deal of time talking
through the community with this what is up
with himu KVM is in and Levert how do they
relate to one another so this is my current
understanding if you know anything is wrong
in here let me know so I gave him his lowest
level time to after I thought was a type one
all this time is actually at 2 to the Linux
kernel requires a reboot app day to change
the maid Kimia with the application in
userspace by simulation for many things
libvirt is a virtualization management
library that uses any one of the silver
salacious meaning including chemo so liver
can use chemo directly or I can use KVM
working use then so when I was using Levert
I was using whatever liver uses and I
suspect underneath it was using KVM but I've
never seen or chemo wait we tried some of
the Kiwi directed things but we were just
call me Lindbergh and liver I believe was
using chemo and I install chemo
DanTDM so I suspect it was just in case
chemo and we got a really Kick-Ass fast on
lennox's tents down the fastest route to
ization there's just no doubt but what are
you paying for by using it
you know what I mean you created a Grammy to
find one
oh wow holy shit that's going in my I'm
screenshotting that
yes I am I have a I have a a thing here
is that screen shot
it's just an easier way than downloading
I take a screenshot and I hit enter and it
publishes it to you my is it for me in my
get
so let's call it which we call this one
Luzerne Kimu
then yeah
Kimu I came in
oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah I mean it's not hard but I didn't yeah
I didn't this is great I was thinking I need
one of these things but it's kind of nice
guest hypervisors
Zen Alienware versabox
alright so that's now in there and I can
actually put that in here
is that blank the first
all right so so that's that's what's up I
think I'm going to go it's just all around
it's more practical and it may have
limitations and slowness and bugs but all
around it made sense that the best way to go
for it for the average development
operations person for what they're going to
want to use it for you so you have ever
compared to a paid application and bring
some boxes not to pay application
registry option is more useful skill to have
I don't agree at all with that I know that
that freaking free and open source Community
thinks that a lot but I think that's could
be a job limiter
and it's slow but it's not like super slow
so
it depends on what your your purposes are my
priority of course is always making
employable skills and and that means using
what the the world uses even if I disagree
philosophically with redhead for example but
his limitations of the in one shift yes that
is my number one reason to not get in Mac
with him one chip
in fact I'm seriously considering never
getting a Mac but I still need to get my
sense of yes
yeah so
so I'm I'm going to stick with that
conclusion for now
and I think for that thing fat diagram that
really helps the diagram really really helps
so you have other hypervisors virtualbox
have her baby
personalization they're the same sort of
thing
and KB I'm chemo has chemo and yeah
and then just not have given it everything
so I delivered give him my dog as a human
form as a 4-star other tools
an armed ship in a laptop I like it too I
just wish it worked
what does exactly
are any BMO and parallels only arm
architecture that's just that kids that's
terrifying that's terrifying that they did
that
I don't I don't think they realize how much
they hurt their Market by doing that
honestly I know they're trying to be
forward-thinking and everything but
they're the developer the crowd I got to
answer this is my wife, from the the car
place I'll be back
well that was my wife that she drove all the
way to Hickory
and there's a hole in the exhaust of the car
so I'm glad they tested that out
what are the tags on this Lenox
devops I don't know secops whatever you want
to call it
I can use what manager on a Mac really
I don't have
memes
do do do do do do
all right so post that one
yeah I think I need to change that actually
2222 host
tags
is that your own where is it real Ariel's
and ID
I want to bring a break anyting
at what time you I notice you wear your your
adding to read me out of the end of it I
think I want to do that now too
yeah it's at I just had that tree get branch
you're you're linking right to the blob I
noticed
I'm thinking to the tree and you're looking
to The Blob and I think the blah bless you
like edited though right
now I think I'm going to like I don't think
I'm going to leave till the read me the
reason is because sometimes I put files in
there
and
if you can yeah I can I'm going to I think
I'm still going to keep blinking to the tree
because when I look to the tree it does
occasionally put other files in there and I
want them to see that there's problems had
to read me in there like something's is
relevant files to go with it you know so
anyway I just I was I just remember you were
doing that today
I liked it so here's our provisioning we are
all done with that now it's time to do the n
f s I would like to get up and make coffee
though
so
cats Echo
what
back
Shawnee Ravenna spend it's reference by the
branch with an ugly
oh so okay that's good yeah that's good too
though
yeah I'm going to be a better set a
reference I'll be right back
I got that coffee is so good God is so good
and now my new Max here going to get that
ready
Life Is Good People life is good learntech
learn code save the world
aren't your daddy's save your job
vagrant we're back on to NFS we're doing FS
today now
so how do we do that well I did an Fs in
another lab
and it was I was trying to set up on
kubernetes kind and actually manage to do it
I set up local nfsc using kind
and that's all good but kind of defeats the
purpose of testing a defense because
I did it but the NFS storage Mount back the
back of the mounts the physical volume that
was backing manifest under darker with kind
was my actual hard drive and I didn't want
to do anything with it
I think I need to put a warning in here it
says morning
doing this turned
to be a really bad idea since none
storage class that uses
PV mad provides
Evie is just a simple volume Mount from
darker
that ends up being the hard drive of the
host computer
whichwhich obviously is useless when testing
filled volume conditions and such
instead consider
the vagrant VM
labs to do the same thing
see related
I don't mind keeping my labs around even if
they turn out to be this didn't work
because I want people to see why it didn't
work and what was the conclusion to the
we need some tortillas what's Chris doing oh
my God
suck my cock
that's funny
Chris is hilarious I really like Chris a lot
so
learning lab set up local on FS and
communities kind
it end
I got to put my other lab.
May I don't even remember what I named it
lab
kids I know this takes extra time but this
extra stuff is what's going to create a
inaudible education history for myself and
and I know it seems unnecessary but it
provides invaluable resource for me to go
back to and to share with others so that's
why I do it's the W and r w x
so
the openness and and steel it says
and I'm going to go ahead and add and thanks
for that
and Link say that
so if anybody runs across this I don't want
them to get the wrong idea.
I mean how many people put their failures on
YouTube
I think if it's a learning lab Discovery
failure I think that that's totally legit I
I would not blame somebody for putting in
putting like shity tutorials and hello world
out there and will probably cause people to
have the wrong impression of your work but
you showing that you know you've you you
made a lab to experiment a possibility in
your conclusions were this is a horrible
idea I don't think that that's it that would
reflect negatively personally so I'm okay
putting that out there
not everybody might agree to that though so
just depends if it if they don't agree then
it's a good filter
that's a good filter it's like a probably
don't want to work there anyway
so what do we got here we've got
what do we have we have bunch of fun stuff
I'm just checking to see if anybody
interesting streaming right now
I'll do it for has been doing a lot to go to
the element recently
and I mean a did a good stuff over there I
just have a really hard time watching them
use the tools that you do it makes me it
makes me stressed out
nothing against them they're great people
and everything that I just
it stresses me out watching the music bunch
of fuzzy finder rust tools and shit in like
okay fine I just don't have to watch it I'd
rather watch you okay
what data is it you kind of yoga
I don't know I mean again it's nothing
personal I just I just not my thing right
alright so let's let's what are we doing
we're kind of like a lot of Festival out of
this one now running an fs and I just found
that spot and I just got myself out of
the reason I even went there in the first
place is because
I wanted to look up all my resources with
this is learning
practice and I'm done I'm a little
frustrated by I don't know what to do so as
I do a learning lab I come up with a lot of
great resources and related material that
ends up Landing in the learning lab but it
doesn't hit in maisel cast and when I do a
search so I have an option and so far they
the fix has been to list the hits
you know to have a reference to it in my
soul casting but then when I do that I have
to go to the vet and then I have to open
this at 9 after I open the related thing and
then you know that point I'm like you know
it's
it's it's not my it's not my favorite so
I don't know what to do there I'm I'm trying
to figure out what to do with that because
all this great content needs to go into my
soul casting as well but I don't want it in
both places because I have to keep it
updated and book places so
I think that the solution is is to
add a tool eventually that searches three
things my chat transcripts which are
currently in zettelkasten my jet content and
my any of my get repos that begin with the
word lab those are the three places that I
maintain data that I need to get to quickly
I need I need to figure out something that's
I've currently been struggling with like see
all these lengths here right well if those
links when is that I could have gone there
and just got it right so that that data
needs to be documented in my soul casting in
addition to the learning lab and
I feel
I don't I don't know what I feel like I mean
if people are coming to the learning lab
they might want to go read some of that
related content I feel like I learn it
giving a person learning lab with no related
content links is kind of means it's like
here's what you have to do and we're not
going to tell you how to do it right I'm
eating that that's the quintessential
learning lab right it's like there's a task
I need to do and I have no fucking idea well
if we give you you know some things to start
with which may or may not still be valid
links I feel like that's a better Head Start
Elsa feel like it's cheating because
to tell you the truth it's
it sounds like the job right the job is you
would have to do your own searches and so by
giving you the search I'm kind of robbing
You by doing the learning lab I say okay
here's the stuff I found for this right and
it's also kind of its cheating is going to
give you half of the battle with a learning
I'm okay I'm going to zoom in with a half of
the battle when you're doing the learning
lab when your doing art of the X method in
any sort of way that you and the allocation
of that method the most important thing that
you're practicing is learning how to get to
the good stuff that whole debate that we
just had earlier about whether you should
read the whole documents about vagrant or
you should like only
you should like only read the essential
documents and then possibly miss a really
important by a variable is going to cost you
an extra hour they could have sat and been
on your way the debate about an Dennis kill
the skill of knowing when to go deep and
your research about a topic or when to just
do the minimum to get the job done in the
moment and had a balance those two against
the requirements of your job or your life or
whatever that's a skill that's a skill
that's the most important skill and so so as
I kind of rubber duck through this I'm
starting to think that these sections at the
bottom of the learning Labs which give you
the hints about where to go to read about it
in addition to you know the solution that's
actually usually provided which is kind of
like my workspace kind of thing that they
they they kind of still you they still had
that they they they they rob you of the of
the opportunity to do your own research on
that so I believe I've made a decision here
I believe in this is what I want really want
to run this by Og I hope he pops in tomorrow
August been really with me on all this
educational stuff so we'll see how it goes
but
I ain't going forward O'Hare. I I think I
think the that's really nice thank you so I
think the future
of this it with of these learning Labs is
going to be what were they started out was
which is a definition of a challenge for you
to go do to learn something and that's it
it's just like here's something go try to
figure this out and then we can reference
that all of us can reference it in our
Solutions so I'll provide a solution either
an example of a solution inside of inside of
here or I could actually write it up in my
zettelkasten and learn how to search and
learn that you agree with that yeah because
if you don't learn that if I can give you
all the links or worse if I give you a
tutorial that tells you exactly what to do
as a part of the Challenger that you know
the learning love I feel like I feel like
you're not going to learn it
because you're not going to struggle right
you're not going to go through and do all
the pain and suffering that's what makes you
learn it and then repeat it right repeating
it over and over again
and then comparing Your solution to what
other people are doing just give me the
commands I can copy paste yeah yeah so so
yeah I feel so I think so a couple things
out and this is one of the recap I'm going
to be removing
the related section from my learning Labs
learning labs are going to contain nothing
more than
then what the goal is right and very rarely
it here's another thing if we do that then
These Warnings that I have about the way
that I did it go away
so I have to fill this NFS vagrant thing
already but I used an old method
and now I have a new method so if I had not
written up my solution here
then you wouldn't be misled by my solution
you would have been creating your own
solution so I think I think maintaining the
learning lab actually independently entirely
from any solution is the way to go and then
I actually think that these sections down
here related whatever instead of that we we
should do is we should be providing a link
into a registry for the discoverable
registry of solutions so they can say I have
here's my solution to this and here's my
solution to this extent here's the commands
this is what they do behind the scenes in
this is what you what you need why you need
it I don't know see that's this is this is
the thing when we do a learning lab is it's
like I still think we need the explanation
of those things so you need any that you
need the presentation of the task at hand
that you would be given at work
or whatever right and you need a
professional opinion about how to do that
and why that matters that's the tutorial
that's the the lead content you know and
then you need to have other people's take on
it right I think you should probably have
other people say going to be able to go to
read through it that's the whole idea behind
check I oh by the way so check I was a coder
site but every one of those Solutions is
voted up based on who they everybody thinks
is the most elegant solution to particular
listen to particular coding challenge
understand my accent on YouTube thanks Jack
hang tight. They're related section this is
something you have to research yourself yes
I still think so so this is this is this is
what I'm going to do I'm not going to take
the related section away from people I'm
going to put the related section into maisel
cast and so I can find it you might not like
you didn't even like the shit that I put in
my related section you may find stuff that's
way better llbg is got way better resources
right so you might even like myself I might
be running you into a wall with my preferred
related section where I was somebody else
has done it was better than me however I do
think we need to give somebody access to
other people who have done this lab so they
can say hey how have you how did you do this
lab why did this like this way I will how
did you do this how I did it this way and
and that's the whole idea behind
the lab registry and we were joking we were
we don't know for sure yet but we're pretty
sure the labs will be associated with a ocms
badge because they're almost identical to
what they were two days to do that and I'll
talk about that over the weekend when we
talked about to get her stuff tomorrow I'll
talk about that yeah hey Google skills
my pretty good Google so serious what is
this about
I sent you staring at that is I guess I'm
weird an email
so have to come to your room so I I feel
like I have got my answer here
NFS in kubernetes all of this stuff needs to
go under I'm going to do it at Safeway
helps triage and yeah
yeah me too me too I can generally tell if
an articles of aspects to stack exchange and
you've been doing it for so long and that
you get a sense of the Triune develop you
know what kind of an instinct and that
instant developing that's an ability right
so abilities just so you know so SKS skills
abilities and knowledge abilities are much
harder to develop because they're they're
kind of you know they're they're harder
they're not as concrete so leadership for
example or you know just scrolling way past
except the answer exactly but those little
techniques that kind of become collectively
inability
hangs more often it works yeah well doesn't
matter that's the what's getting use
so yeah I'm going to actually add this to
something else really quick edit an FS
see this right here at this is me linking to
a project and then had shit all over the
place so I think I I I feel good about this
this stuff that we talked about
hopes that I deleted I guess I must have
yeah
I know what I did there
all right give me a second
I got local communities I mean he's run my
own notes right
and I also need to edit this guy I'm glad I
caught a nip this in the bud before I did it
too much because I was providing links to my
learning Labs but it it's stupid it's just
empty useless thing and I don't want that I
want I want my best to have interesting data
and I don't want them to be linked to some
other thing that can't be searched so so
that's the end of that
yeah so so yeah we got that
I I need to make a conclusion on that
no later
I concluded that putting anything
that robs the Lerner from the practice of
searching for their own Solutions does not
be long in the learning lab
content and instead all
work on ways to link to a registry of people
who have completed the lab and written up
there examples notes and solutions for
comparison
I really want to hook
yeah because I've stopped
Daisy G tally now
yeah n f s doesn't have bugs from trying to
say people still use it though
hello it's far from perfect it remains
the most popular pic for enabling
Ross Pod Storage in kubernetes therefore
understanding
how it works and testing it is a mandatory
skill
or any
caretti's infrastructure engineer
thanks for that link
yeah yes
sabbaticals hours hanging out if you still
there
all right so I feel good about that that's I
really need to talk about that stuff with a
dog when he's when he's on I think
tomorrow's education day so
I'm going to go and see Cody tomorrow all
day but then after that we would talk about
education. And Sunday is our big interview
stay so he riding a bunch of being a Content
back to work stuff though so
I kind of feel like I need to remove this
example as well the hardest part about this
is
I don't really want to have a lab and then
you know
a separate place for my solution that
doesn't seem to it's a jive with me I don't
know and now I'm having a hard time with
that but you know what I mean
it's like what's where we put it like where
which area do we do we put it
I don't know I don't know and I shouldn't be
stressing about this right now but I'm
you know what
it's like you need a place to post the labs
and then you need a place to post the word
for
what's the word for your developing the lab
your kind of in the middle of solving it and
presenting the challenge at the same time so
you really don't know what the final version
of its going to be actually don't even know
where your testing you don't know what the
steps and yours in the middle of exploring
and doing all kinds of shit in there and I I
feel like that that should be that should
that should be in there I
I think I just figure it out though I'm
going to change example to work I'm going to
make a work directory in here and that's
just going to be the standard the work
directory is that's where I'm doing my work
for that laugh and then we can make labs and
you can like you know copy it up and replace
work with your own work you know it at your
been doing it
so yeah I don't know
seating at work directory yamo
yeah that nothing really here
yeah this is also where I'm posting my own
solutions to it right so here's this is
stuff I was looking for how to install the
NFS Colonel actually this is all related.
What you don't want to do either that's
another thing to is just like
yeah I'm just a
is banana sugar extra safe for Vive I can
kind of Steal these lines though
yeah I can I can do all right
I ran to see that so yeah
yeah I'm going to fix this later
the first related I I think and put the
related notes in my own notes
hell I can actually put all that in my my
own
cephalic images similar to that of the
pricing problem interesting
set up an FS server setup benefits client
set up nfsr on control
clients on are curved
Parker to ship sure none is Melanie
and where the stars class do creative play
MattyB now alright so
hi this is so I don't know how to do that
set up an FS server on control
creating an episode with Baker and Arsenal
and forgiving is closer there is one that
we've tried already
it's a dark Sonic so it's the same though
I know taking the metal casting stuff yeah
it's a lot to talk about so
it Narrows the stuff I've done on it
can get a common overview of what I've done
if I follow the Nicholas aluminum sell
casting method using a script that in route
for that which is not baked I'm going to be
bringing making that into an official thing
we're going to make it part of keg as well
then I'll just change.
Yeah so
get your Monday yeah pretty much
let's go see this thing
I read the Arts blog about this I'm not that
that's not the one
copy link
alright so Pittsburgh has not been resolved
what I thought we'd got rid of
what the fuc from
but I am Deb to is not one of my favorite
places to go for information but whatever
Savannah learning about Risa travel there's
a vagrant file I sent you a benefits server
Sophia's memory and name
and then what we have and if it's not being
provision
shell batteries rough out hip fun is it if
it's there at the falling of a Sarge
how do you spell razor Appleton is what
afterwards all my content
I used I used tags and title searching
that's what I do I do I was I was kind of
like I don't know if I was going to use tags
or not but I went ahead and do it I have a
standard format for my markdown I have a
related section and have a tag section and I
never ever put URLs without printing them
out because then they there they don't show
up in front of documentation and and that
doesn't work for YouTube and stuff like that
where you can't do markdown links so
the command to multiple Gary post and have a
simple keg yeah that's that's exactly what
we're talking about Bolivia yeah yeah we've
been doing we've been doing it for about a
year now and this weekend we're probably to
talk about that anybody wants I just a side
note if anybody wants to tune in so tell me
what is now using is that method pretty
heavily well and and they're using it from
their phone and so we have some some some
words if, so we're we're bringing back the
keg The Keg and said stuff so when we talked
about this weekend some point I don't know
when it means note means to slip actually
yeah it slip box
Notre slip I like the word slip because it's
not a card people think it means card it
doesn't does it's not a car stuck in fact
Nicholas Lumen actually specifically says
cardstock is too thick so you know and
there's a reason for that so
so let's go back to this box to find some
machine a minister with the following
properties we don't care about that this is
what we want to see we want to see how
to update the house file okay
so this is where I have to write this in my
solution and I'm I'm wondering how to do
that
it's like the thing about a challenges like
how specifically do you get to do you say
this is the step set up an end of Sir well
how do you do that how you break that down
right and
it's time sheets maybe who knows so
so that means even provision I can say
they disable swap
age play style there and we say
I actually like using Code rather than
writing about it I'm out of bed feels
welcome
and if it still hurts at the end of the
server on control
so if Christopher is working to update the
host file and
I don't know if we're going to need that
I'm going to have to this going to be a post
for vision
I don't think I need to do that down as
someone if the server
nfsu tilz is the same one actually
weightless find it was find a red hat 1 as
sitting up
red hat if you're in if it's already in 57
FS
I was going to put him here for now and then
come out later but
alright so
I'm here we go red hat training
there are two ways you can figure out a
Pfister so Forsyth installing a pisser
and we're going to go get on one of the
servers right now actually let's put the
paint on that payment
I don't mean like that like pain pain
vagrants SSH
control so we have a control server up that
we already bought up with fragrant and now
we need to do it we need to do
Sea-Doo I thought that install
n f s server and client
and I mean that so Sea-Doo yum
that's why I update
did Yung Dash date right then
we need to do I think somebody told me it
comes this when we come in at red hat comes
within a n f s enabled how do we even know
that
how can I tell if an offense is enabled
I had a fence is running on the server
oh that is JavaScript for this shity page
make a note of this absolutely shity
nixcraft page that will never use again
this is a perfect example of why the
internet's going to shit this is a
documentation page that requires JavaScript
to see it someone tell me how that's a good
thing
at 7 tell me how that's a good thing I do
not buy it
jerky Master links users nfsd does
everything have to have a necessity for this
98th Avenue service nfsd
Sirius NFL status I should see if nfsc is on
there
anyways just got
I like the minister also I better there's a
I watch an hour-long video from the team who
made it Windows 10 they made it there really
good
all right so assist you this this UPS a u x
o r a e f n f
FS yeah there is no manifest
there is no one at Fester ouz Lynx ever
why would you want JavaScript Frank why do
you need JavaScript
AniLinkz doesn't fully support the dumb or
any of all JavaScript so that's not even a
true saving I know
why the fuck do you need JavaScript in a
document page you can't justify that can't
justify
the whole world is going crazy this morning
this morning I read a whole thing about how
hmx is the new thing because JavaScript is
it everything now and I'm like has a whole
collectible lost their fucking minds
who wants to forcethe force everybody to use
JavaScript to read a man page effectively
has anyone MSL mystery yeah
I have a headache
I know they don't
more and more are not working with a
JavaScript but I but it's stupid not to
mention those pages can't even be searched
are ruining the web they're totally fucking
ruining it and this is why I started the
essential web and then I'll just change. And
this is why a ton of other people are
thinking of things of go for another step
because because the people that are in
charge of making these web decisions are
fucking destroying it the creator of the web
has come out vocally against what's
happening to the web right now and all these
JavaScript script Kitty fucktard just keep
ruining it
with wild abandon you're just an old angry
guy do I have to be an old angry guy to
appreciate a documentation site that doesn't
have JavaScript on it
now you got me
seriously I just I cannot stop getting angry
about that that has nothing to do with my
age has to do with practicality
guess what I got a fever
and the only
and the only solution is more JavaScript
wait I got to get back
this will make me happy
find my happy place by my happy place again
if you don't believe me
go read the JavaScript sites and search
mailing list from Google where everybody's
sites Enterprise sites are getting destroyed
by a JavaScript interns are coming in and
fucking destroying whole set like my site
doesn't work it can't be searched anymore no
one can get anything and then I can say we
had interns come his fucking hilarious
the man they got some cool whiz-bang little
dumb shit from JavaScript on there but now
their sites completely unsearchable by
Google
the dancers are gone they're gone in the
dumb asses who hired those people to come in
and do that shit now they're left with the
crap and if you want her freed story after
story after Story of people in a panic
because their websites no longer searchable
or because they broke in it and some of the
way with JavaScript when it was just a
documentation landing page for the company
go read it
can't even see the fucking page anymore yeah
it's like you know this sounds with
JavaScript came out everybody was pissed too
because he would people were like making you
know shit spin on the screen and stuff in
and we're like
and now it's just taking over in the whole
world's gone fucking idiotic is full of
theocracy
and that's why I anyway so that you don't
have to be an old person to appreciate the
ability to use a website with documentation
without JavaScript
there's no fucking reason to put
documentation it would JavaScript in it and
if you do you should use view or something
that'll enable you to have an interactive
graph or something that's a part of your
documentation which doesn't destroy the rest
of your fucking page
or accessibility by there and you get a
million-dollar lawsuit that you lose like
Pizza Hut because they did that they did
that and they lost accessibility and they
lost in court so you guys don't think this
is an issue think it's just some old guy
ranting but it's not it's much more than
that
it's my biggest pet peeve of modern
technology.
What gets overrun by people who can fresh
air to coding bootcamp so they absolutely
are that's exactly what's happening yeah and
then they ate they are necessarily use their
big fancy ass thing that they learn to they
don't know anything else and it's so unsexy
to use plain old HTML and CSS meanwhile you
have an entire Schism
Schism in fact the guy who made the guy who
made code pin wrote about this is rolled
several blogs about the Schism in web
development between the designers who
celebrate HTML and CSS without any used to
JavaScript and and the other people who are
like make all the things JavaScript and
there's this message kids and continue to
this day problem is the designers are losing
the designers are losing the designers are
picking up Tailwind bigger they want
Tailwind because it's JavaScript and it's
just easier than what the fuck around with
CSS they're losing it designers who are like
pushing HTML and CSS and good practices and
sustainability in and look the same be able
to read change the looks just by changing
the style see those people are fucking
losing because of things like k
and and then at the end of the day or all of
the web is going to be a big JavaScript
monstrosity that's going to be completely
unsecured and that's why we need a new one
Tim berners-lee the creator of the web
himself is calling for a new one because
it's so fucked up everybody is being
motivated to link out not everybody has been
just SE Google SE always cause people to be
penalized in their search results because
they are linking out to other stuff that
means they're not as authoritative Tortura
Tatum is how many links you have in so
Google single-handedly has destroyed its
original purpose of collaboration by linking
to other people's content the more that you
link out to somebody else to lower your
ranking in search results
how fucked up is that
the Privacy being an illusion from the past
privacy is an illusion from the past but
that doesn't mean I don't value it
use of JavaScript and it got documentation
side of that illusion from the past no
no it's not I'm not going to wake up one day
and decide that every single web page that
has documentation on it should have
JavaScript enabled
yeah and then they got rid of that slogan
they removed it and removed it
at your job a certain HTML yeah
yeah it's the biggest problem is that
there's no separation between web documents
and web applications and I wrote a Blog on
this one 2007-2009 something there's no
separation of the System of a Down
you know I look it's it's fine it's what it
is
comments should be after illusions
that is an allusion in the past yes
and I don't know why you no let me let me
just say I just summarize I
I can't get mad about it but I can do
something about it and the thing that I can
do is I can create systems for people who
matter
to communicate quickly and easily through
text only through text and mineral wrestler
images and I'm not the only one who's doing
this there have been and Terra moments of
people they've been pushing for gopher and
other Alternatives even distro to get a
whole thing on it and there is a strong
demand for efficient and quick Google less
ability to get the information there is a
strong demand and it's not where the fucking
30 it's something else and I want to build
that something else I already have already
started so and even if I die and it doesn't
go anywhere at least I'll know that I did
something about instead of just complain
yeah and Shadow dumb I know they do it's
insane
didn't have the right the problem was is it
the issue was already too complicated they
should have just stuck with document-sharing
but nobody just wants document sharing the
original at this is something people don't
realize the original web didn't let you
change your styles
the original web people are the original web
the original web was a glorified Kindle
reader
even remember this
anybody remember the original purpose of the
web was a glorified Kindle reader it put all
the power in the consumer's hands
you going to a web page and you would say I
can't read this font I need to turn the
phone up for all web pages and you would
change the font in you can see if the reason
she's the reason they visited link is purple
and not blue is because that original design
was that everybody would be unified in their
style that words and ideas would be
Paramount that they would matter more than
anything else and that images and an
emphasis would be added in order as a form
of communication the original web was a
glorified Kindle reader with pictures
you could not add a background and it took
this shit heads at Netscape to come along
and say we're going to ruin all of that
we're going to have the blank tag we're
going to add backgrounds we allow you to any
color font you want we're going to allow you
to blow that shit away and were going to
give all the power to the people creating
the content and said the people consuming
the content
and ever since then the world the World Wide
Web is gone fucking downhill and that's not
just cuz I'm old that's because it has and
the reason I am so fro text browser are you
watching me for an hour and browsing on the
doing it research from thing the most
annoying thing I do is text browser and get
past all this shit from the menu at the top
so that you know as soon as they get past
that all the text is the same it's all the
same color it's all the same size I can find
information 10 times faster than the average
person with a graphic browser because I have
a consistent interface for reading
and that's why the Kindle work so well for
baby provide consistory experiences for
people with all types of sizes to get
somebody who's Haile visually impaired they
can just crank the van up now you can still
do all that shit but it's extremely hard to
do it now and almost always it breaks it so
that the stylistic design people got Rick
got a hold of the web first and they're the
first people to fuck it up and then the
second people to fuck it up as a JavaScript
people say fuck your Stiles is all just
JavaScript so let's just go there and they
have destroyed the World Wide Web as we know
it they have destroyed it they have made the
world vitamin to this big flashy piece of
shit that nobody can get any information on
quickly it's completely biased based on
confirmation bias engines to use Neil
Degrassi Tyson storm for Google
it's ruined and we need a new one we need to
throw the whole fucking thing out and make a
new one that's based on knowledge it's based
on information that's based on rings of
trust instead of centralized search engines
and that is a knowledge exchange bread if
you want a more about it just give you a
push for this we're going to start building
that out we've already started with her
settle cast and stuff we're just going to
make it so you can stare share your Zello
castles with each other and with a manifest
and you can quickly determine its or an RSS
way whether somebody has been updated or not
then you can follow the people you want to
who actually matter people not all this shit
that Google's going to throw in front of you
but you can still have that but then you can
see all this person posting something new
with this Wilson from said something new and
you can use the followers only kind of
situation so that you can control yourself a
notch and use your own as CEO validation
because the content is organized in such a
way that you can Define your own sto
parameters you have to have to bow down to
Google's fucking shity SEO you can make your
own premises say you want to do a search for
everything is in the secondary
well because everything is just mark down
and all this stuff is essential is in the
same format you can easily do that you can't
do that on the web today because they fucked
up the standard
I'm done
yeah so I'm not Pike by the way
yeah yeah
so get secure way for sharing papers and
nice so crazy about that Lorde rubbish that
is the exact reason as CERN the Hadron
Collider that is the exact reason the
scientist invented the fucking world wide
web that is the reason they invented it was
to share knowledge to documents
and now you can't even do it you can't you
can't do it
it's like now
it's like I'm it's just like
okay let's do this was my masi masi camera
did all right instead of using Facebook
exactly
they're fucking and sucking I guess that's
one of them actually it's a funny
yeah I know this is you know and it has
knowledge on it oh my God this is great this
should be the epilogue of the rent for every
rent
yeah it's
you until I get talking like that and people
see my beard in my age and they will guide
Lansing at Cloud oh sorry web
yeah it's like you know
do they still do a fact the more significant
the person the less they have on their
webpage with regard to style and I I'm in a
home by that
yeah the author of a go look at his side
because that shit to do and say they don't
want to fuck around South look I am not
against good design
I'm not against who designed I think certain
document secret is that I just don't think
you should throw usability out the window
and searchability it if you're going to do I
am not against web applications
I think using the web platform as a delivery
mechanism for really complex applications to
clean webassembly everything it's a
fantastic idea just stop mixing your Oreos
in your peanut butter or whatever the fuck
because if you do documents great keep it a
document I'm going to do a really Kick-Ass
application is Scarab assembly and all kinds
of shit in their fine I don't care just
don't mix the two when you mix it to then
you can't search it you can't search the
stuff you throw them both out but then
that's it should be basic understanding I
was really happy to hear that Leon was
talking about that very thing Leon was
talking about this very thing as a
progressive web design and I paid him ten
bucks to get a bit to show up on a screen
that says stop putting JavaScript in your
documents and and and he was saying the same
thing to her you know, the filter boot camp
class group you know 6,000 people are
looking at it just the boot camps the
stomach that they don't they don't do it
don't talk about him
that is my function of her pregnant yeah I
know
all right I think I'm done so because we
just hit one I actually have a shit list of
sites that do that I stop maintaining cuz
they're just making me angry
hey your favorite how are you yeah and so
yeah yeah
I said what do you think of couples
relaxation OSHA training talk about that
I don't know you want my short answer is it
depends
the short answer is it depends I think I
think the government should have the right
to make a post for a vaccination absolutely
as a public health that the purpose of the
government is public health and if the
government can't legally require you to get
a vaccination the what the fuck is the
purpose of the government I want to be
protected from the idiot next to me who's
going to do some things it's overwhelmingly
stupid like oh I don't know you know do the
meth lab in his in his closet
it's going to be so Dennis said I think the
government's absolutely have the right to
determine if vaccinations or fluoridation of
the water or things like that should be
happening to this defected the problem is
not that the governments are bad the problem
is that the government's no longer represent
the will of the people and that's a
different problem that's a totally different
problem and the perp that's the purpose of
government also nobody can properly enforce
it right
yeah yes
it should be in the same vein as just asked
where there is no Reasonable Doubt yeah
exactly what there's a reasonable doubt it's
if we can't depend on the rule of law
government then we're all fucked
doesn't mean I like our present government
or the way it operates her how busted it is
but it did but the rule of law and
government is historically been shown to be
the way to do things and and I don't know if
that means representative government or
Republic's or oligarchies or dictatorships
that night but getting into that but the
role of government is to protect the people
and part of protecting the people who is
deciding what vaccinations should happen and
if you don't
and if you don't agree with how they're
doing that your government should have the
means for you to to organize that I'm going
to be in so much corruption people would
have an easier time getting vaccinated agree
I agree completely but it's a different
problem yeah it is not useful for him good
for him a bit strange points I'm not saying
don't get vaccinated I'm saying that you
have a choice
and I am not an anti vaxxer but
my youngest son had autism and we got him
vaccinated we had the MMR shot we forgot
that he was a month premature and we got him
his vaccinations for them are we got in a
really cheap cheap places we were dead
dirt-poor we didn't go we got the one that
had ThermaSol with the mercury in it and I
know that it's all been debunked I've heard
it a million times but the circumstantial
evidence of the situation was that I feel
like if I had waited an extra month and a
half that whatever it is I don't believe it
was a trigger I'm not afraid of vaccines but
I feel like I cried I literally was crying
over my son didn't want trying to decide
whether to go get him in the next day or not
because my second son actually because I
knew that the first son had his autism
showed up almost exactly to the date 2
months after we got them the next day and he
started it completely acted differently and
people say oh that was just a coincidence
and then I said okay that's fine it probably
was a coincidence but my kid was was diff
within two months after getting after
getting the MMR shot and nobody has any
proof of anything and it could have been
just coincidence and all the other things
that they say and I'm not an anti-vaxxer I
still think I should have happened my
personal personal feeling on this is at not
scientific at all my personal hypothesis is
that there are certain people in the world
are particularly those who come from those
who are a scientific or technical or
whatever who are prone to autism who have a
susceptibility to autism and that there are
certain environmental factors that trigger
the autism that they need they Trigger or
they they bought theirs people who have
reverse their autism through control of gut
bacteria and stuff like that so that I
believe that's my personal hypothesis I know
I'm not an expert in any by any means but I
personally believe that that that that there
is yet and yet unexplained phenomenon that
happens it's not been totally corrupted by
mainstream media and drama and all that
stuff we can never get in
an actual control answer to this because
it's been so fucked up but all the media and
everything we need to actually have some
pure science go in and and study what are
the you know genetic factors of any what are
the unit predispositions to it like like you
know like we have sickle cell anemia that
affects a particular genetic group we have
certain things I may have some people I
think that are susceptible to autism in the
north certain environmental triggers one of
which might have been ThermaSol Mercury that
cause a note that is given to us at 2 a.m.
to a child who's Too Young that may have
have caused some of that stuff to kick in a
little bit earlier and I don't have any
proof of that at all and that's that's
repeating some things that have been then
while they be debunked by fraudulent shit
head scientist who made it impossible to
make the conclusion that might agree with
those scientist someday because he's has
been so drawn out so I don't know I look I
do not trust a lot of the stuff that happens
in the with the money involved with the
Pharmaceuticals in the interest
and stuff like that there's really clearly
situations where pharmaceutical companies
have made decisions that are not in our best
interest but then there is also
circumstances were pharmaceutical companies
have saved entire civilization so we need
them at it's more complex is not black and
white it's not this goes here that goes
there it's like it's a complex thing and we
have to navigate it one decision at a time
and if if you know you know I think that's a
tough thing I wish I wish you many of the
best yeah it was really really hard is my
only means of people to get the opportunity
vaccinate against covid still see a lot of
people don't care I don't want it to spend
the night can be forever else I want to go
to Midtown this point people are getting it
all the time cuz they ain't cuz they're just
they just let their there is a Rossman
talking about this the other day too he's
like he's just tired people just tired
people with illnesses and old people with
health concerns aren't
okay so here's one why doesn't everybody get
a flu shot every year
you can you can pick and choose your
your vaccination conversation and you'll get
different answers depending on the depending
on the vaccination
right if you have a conversation about the
MMR vaccination you're going to get a very
heated conversation with regards to those
who have autism stuff if you pick if you
pick a
why can we not even discussing her so much
hysteria that's that in a little bit I'm
glad you said that because that is Dennis
Teague Tennessee core of the issue we cannot
have respectful disagreements anymore in and
we certainly can't change our minds when
presented new information because oh my God
how dare I admit I was wrong we have
inflamed these issues so high and I would
blame social media for that we've been
slammed all these issues so high we can't
even have a scientific debated conversation
about it so that when we have a conversation
and there's new information and we take the
scientific method we can accept the changes
we can say no I was wrong on that we need to
learn to be able to say I was wrong let's
move forward
and God knows I need that right and I
believe I've done a lot better with that
unless she said what year was actually but
there's a sinkhole backfire effect which is
if you tell somebody they're wrong it will
dig their heels in this is scientifically
proven there's lots of studies on this you
can watch the Adam ruins science on this one
and they will dig their heels in and they
will like they're deliberately prove
themselves right because it feels that your
neural Center in your brain lights up for
pain when you're when you're told your wrong
and hurtful to do something so then you
don't want it and I know this how many times
have I gotten on somebody's back because
I've been right and I've had to accept that
they were right and it's painful to
physically painful to say you were wrong
it's like oh my God this hurts so bad and so
some people will never admit they're wrong
under any circumstances even if you told him
everything attack ideas not people it's hard
to do with emotions are absolutely and I do
it all the time
yeah and then you have people like me who
grew up in a time where we we joke around
with each other that we respect and we call
each other morons and idiots and stuff and
there's the implied assumption that you're
not a moron we're just we're just friends
here but we're we're we're doing that toxic
masculinity thing you know where we call
each other more as we have seen Torvalds is
the king of this right but it's not good
because when you have a communication form
like this where you're not even able to
speak you know you just type something and
it comes across as me getting punched in the
vaccination thing is yet another one in a
series of issues that's really Sunrise well
and death to 2022 where we've just forgotten
how to communicate with each other we
forgotten that we're all human that we all
need to be able to communicate and if we all
need to be able to talk through things and
we all need to be happy able to have
significant disagreements and I mean you'll
be able to say people are downright.
Wrong and not take offense when we say that
they're dead wrong instead of them feeling
like they're being personally attacked me to
take we need to be feel like we're being
attacked us and we need to attack us and
that that's my my my my case on that but
yeah we can't even have a conversation about
vaccinations cuz it's so fucking done with
politics tribalism s over yeah it's like
what what are the what are the conservatives
think on this okay yeah okay let's go to go
go go let's go you know it's like
but probably not for vaccines I'm not saying
it's from vaccines I didn't say autism came
from vaccines I said that my hypothesis is
that there are several environmental
triggers for autism that occur at different
stages and that I personally think there is
such a netiq predisposition to autism that
we eventually should be able to diagnose it
and stuff and I studied lots of them a lot
because I have two kids is about to summon
have dealt them a lot yeah we don't need to
care for my future to be more communicate
with each rational yeah I agree with that
but I've been accused by entire community of
not being that
you know it's like it's like when I attack
web developers and I jokingly say in a web
developers are not developers they take
offense to that and you know nothing I can
do about that when I say that you know
JavaScript should die and people to do job
everyday is their job then they take
personal offense of that
and I take personal offense when people say
I'm a horrible programmer
eventually I'll get over it but I'm just as
susceptible as anybody as
as private primarily a web developer I do
not take offense at yeah you know it's not
the first of all you need to know about me
what is if you feel like you're being
attacked pause and ask yourself is he
attacking something I love or is he
attacking me personally I think that goes
for anything it's super easy to get offended
by people attacking what you love people
attack or the people promoting what you hate
people come in here in Pearl trust all the
time and say how awesome rust is and I do
feel a little attachment I have to defend
myself it at the same time I want to hear
what I have to say so
yeah there is always one guy said well
that's I don't know about that that's a good
way to go about doing it we're definitely
humans definitely do that but I don't know
if it's healthy I don't know if it's healthy
enough to re-establish your value by saying
you're better than somebody else I think
there's another way and I don't know fully
how to take you late without his but I don't
think that's the best way to sell
Facebook for programmers
other than just go hang out and do stuff I
don't like people or Community you mean
they're probably is
it depends what kind of program you're doing
right back to vote
magical winter gear that too and I break the
rust issues comes up because I did it's it's
I'm so characterized the back of any kind of
bags on Rust I said several times to her
many many things that are very good about
rust people don't remember because I so
obsessed with all the things I hate about it
and then and then there's that very
difficult the situation where a person
cannot be disassociated from the technology
and and that is very hard right
imposter syndrome yeah
now at Boston was a thing to I think though
that if you feel offended by what I say or
with somebody else says I think you need to
step back and ask yourself are they
attacking me or are they attacking something
I love cuz it's different
I might attack something that you dearly
dearly loved I might attack your religion
that you cherish am I attacking you
strictly speaking I'm not attacking you
I can say that I Think Jesus is a crazy ass
fantasy thought up by a bunch of you know
wannabe Assyrians it doesn't matter because
I'm attacking a thought system or a belief
system the problem is is it as soon as you
get into the loss of funeral Legend and
politics and I are tagging things that go
deep with people you're attacking things
that go really deep with people in that if
you attack Jesus you're attacking them
and they can't set the can't distinguish it
and I think the problem is is it people have
gotten that way with dumb shit things like
entities for example people feel like a
religious affinity for entities if you say
that in a teaser dumbass horrible things
that should never exist they'll take it
personally as if you accused you know that
you could check the religion because people
get really really passionate my biggest
problem and challenges that I get so fucking
passionate about stuff that other people
just doesn't matter
and as soon as I get passionate about
something like that I feel offended if you
don't if you don't acknowledge the value of
the thing that I'm passionate about like
Linux for example right that's why I just
went to fuck off fun on Linux on on Linda's
align us actually on Linus Tech tips that
one day when he was there with his whole
Community was feuding absolute idiocy about
Linux and I was like I went off and it
became a personal thing because I was like
feeling personal attack because I had to
defend Lennox since the day I was born
practically in the tech world
so you get you get personal as soon as it
gets personal you're fucked because they
can't disassociate yourself from what's
going on and now I can now you're starting
to tell him he's trying to attack their
mother Yo Mama
can you do I start a question of motivation
or just the show going for greedy profit
from your
your dumbass marketing sponsors and yeah
devolving with technology oh God
I could not agree more with that but I don't
think any of teas are themselves all by
themselves bad I think the ability to have a
method of exchange for digital Goods that
creates uniqueness is totally acceptable
I I actually throw the the Baseline
non-fungible token approach to creating
uniqueness even if it costs us our planet
and energy
I think seeking a way to create a unique
digital asset is a valid Noble Pursuit and
that there's a lot of digital things that
people should be able to choose to sell I
absolutely agree with that and I think we
desperately need that in our time and I
think we need to find something that's not
related a blockchain personally but I think
creating uniqueness is is is a very valuable
thing I think that's a very valuable thing
to create digital uniqueness I mean we've
experienced this over and over again with
TF2 hats and all kinds of things the world
wants the ability to exchange digital assets
and that by itself is totally fine how it's
used in deployed in the quality of the yard
and all that stuff is out there all separate
issues to me
they're not do so many people can't
distinguish the end of tissue from that
they're like Mary at the hip so they can't I
can't really can only do it anyway Sears
days to do I'm going to guess here young
Dash Why install nfsu tools
and I think I think I'll get a sad Sooyoung
that's why I install
nfsu tells I think that includes this the
server and the other stuff
sudo systemctl NFL s
there's no such thing as I do really
so what else we got here
brightness to see do you want to know if
it's if it's D
f s n f s client how do I get to server
r v c pipe with us and if he's credited in
FS
excessive people want to use it to buy she
let him I should know yeah
Argenta Mike totally agree I agree with your
statement argentum completely I think I
think we should seek out opportunities for
people to buy to do that I think that's an
enabling technology that enables digital
creators to have a place at the table in
this world of capitalism in exchange you
know I I think they deserve a place at the
table hands down do I think that the that
the gorillas and lions are like
you know an expression of amazing art and no
but that's a subjective decision that's
that's not related to the base technology
he thinks yeah
yeah and I mean I like the whole idea of
being able to make digital baseball cards I
think that's fucking crazy awesome I think
the same law should apply I don't think you
should make a Chris Nova trading card
without asking Chris Nova which Christopher
has talked about Kristen Bell and Kelsey I
down a bunch of bunch of cloud native people
got made in 10 of teas without their asking
being asked about that and they got kind of
pissed
hey how's it going kid
nor can a factor of 12 Years the night shift
the relays for a few months how to make him
to do for a your thoughts actually the whole
video series on that and I'm going to be
making another one so let me so here's a
calendar
fact if you go to the counter counter is
posted on the Boost Re-Boost is May 4th is
the time to wrap up that where you can we do
a c c coding
sealcoating very specific opinions about
this please get you know a second opinion
about what you might want to do one of those
second opinions I would suggest would be
learning with Leon who focuses on what to do
in the careers that we don't have one yet
I'm sorry I mean I've been meaning to give
you one here's the here's a boost you at all
and you can go there and read it the 20 20
20 20 20 20 20 20 21 boost covers containers
and stuff like that just noticed about me I
I I I recently wrote a thing about this is
that Chat best
job this is an important distinction between
myself and what I see others trying to do
sometimes so I believe the best jobs are
related to the Linux terminal and to those
kinds of things in the industry in the world
those of the jobs that people need so I'm
focused on that just know that there's
people you know people faster than then I
would choose to prepare you just depends on
your own music concert tickets real estate
absolutely still a pictograph excuse to
start angry and if these are fine the fact
that they can use for that is unless it's
like just like all the other issues we've
been talking about is Jaden the conversation
you can't have a conversation by entities
right now because they're still at the only
fight I mean you disagree with my light
before
the only topic that I brought up that
immediately invoked a fight or flight
response with my artist wife in the Fine
Arts within a t s I brought it up and I was
like hey do you want to talk about this and
she got visibly pissed off she like how the
fuck anybody about me she was Angry Angry
Angry so you got to be careful we can't even
have a conversation like I'm not attacking
you I'm just asking a question do you think
people in the digital realm should be able
to exchange their art and create unique this
and she would say no
and I think I think that's unfair
just because you're a fine artist who does
painting murals in space $300 for a frame on
a piece of glass that some you know
oil-bearing can invite and hang in their
house how how is that art different than
digital art is it was better at take Squire
quality though that's a pretty condescending
approach to Arts from somebody who is very
biased towards the Fine Arts and I love my
wife dearly you guys know it but the concept
of Digital Arts being on par with Fine Art
to her is downright vomitus she will like
she can't even stomach it it just makes you
so angry
but I still think she's wrong I'm hungry to
death I just think she's wrong on that point
I think art should not be bound to a
particular medium
I don't and if your Ringo Starr and you want
to make a bunch of shit in in my Ms paint
and sell it for $9,000 a pop that should be
here Friday in the real world by the way
don't put like a big blotch on the on a
piece of on the wall and I'll sell it for 10
grand because art is extremely subjective
I guess I came in the right conversation our
yeah we're just having fun here I didn't we
change the topic but we're kind of doing
both
the current state of cryptocurrencies do
this right now okay I guess I got to change
my status in
let's change the Chillin is so you won't get
mad at me since
best yeah now at least when the property
proper Channel what do I think about
what do I think about her sitting from the
currency one of the problems you see you
then when the switch is it from I talked
about that a lot actually
and my we we actually
we actually want to make a
I want it one of my emotes is going to be
crypto Ian
I'm so tired of hearing about crypto I'm
just so tired of hearing about it so my
position on crypto walls down and again I I
have a dear dear friend Ricardo who
Ricardo who is a keynote speaker for crypto
has been for years he started Foundation to
use crib for the 24 quarter for Humanity
he's done number of amazing things and he
and I have had in the past buried over beer
read me page but he always buys the beer by
the way
he buys all the beer and he sends me say
businesses be Christmas cards and Gifts the
stuff he's the nicest guy I really like him
a lot I miss him actually I really miss him
and he's a huge huge crypto fan and I'm not
I tried really hard to get into it mostly
because of him and the more I got into it we
have to give a presentation to a group of
people would have been one of whom was at a
senior executive in a company and she has a
simple question who's going to pay for all
the power and I'd never even thought of that
and if you see that now that's kind of a
meme on the Internet is you know the amount
of crypto to do Bitcoin is powering entire
small countries and it's just getting worse
and then you have proof of stake enter the
conversation with the theory of them and
some of the other cryptos that sponsored it
first and now that there is kinda getting
pressured into doing it and Bitcoin said no
we're never doing that so it's encrypted as
being associated with buying things that are
illegal and blah blah blah and then he got
the whole Twitter.
Something and then you know everybody's
trying any idea what's going on dude you
know I I just don't care my fundamental
position on crypto is I think that you we
should explore blockchain technology even
though I think it's a failed technology you
know in a trust free environment because the
51% attack and that's an opinion that shared
by Brian Ford has an extensive formal you
know post-graduate levels of analysis on on
the algorithms for blockchain and where they
would go from a societal aspect and I
totally agree I agree with those people
actually asked him point-blank I said what
do you think you were one of the people who
knows a lot about this and he checked in for
me and he said his assessment of the 51%
attack real and he said absolutely so I
don't think blockchain is a sustainable
replacement for currency nor has it ever
been even though the people lived a lie to
you
the biggest complaint about the crypto stuff
is all the misrepresentation by the Creek
community which I'm not completely convinced
isn't it for Motivated by self game and and
that's the biggest complaint I have it the
first came out we were going to be ordering
pizza with it and then it took 35 minutes to
even do a process this transaction they said
oh it's not forwarding peace anymore it's
about being the new gold and then it became
something else and it became something else
and now they're giving us you know this new
thing and all the while they don't talk
about what it really means for the world and
I can't help but think that this is just a
technical it's just a power grab from the
technology sits at 2 to take back you know
when it attacked via currency is his big war
between near the Techno heads and then the
old Warren Buffett types of people and and I
don't want any part of it because I don't
think any of it is working towards the
benefit of society and Jen
including more than half the world's
population doesn't have a fucking computer
or internet access and we're spending so
much time figuring out how to do blockchain
transactions an event web 3.0 and all this
other shit that but we don't spend a second
of that energy and time trying to figure out
how to solve The World's real problems which
are you know getting everyone a computer or
getting them access to technology getting
him access to give people access to
technology they'll figure out how to get
access to water
they'll figure out how to create Prosthetics
where they can't before and there's amazing
story about that about these people these
Carpenters who'd lost a thumb collaborating
with these fingers puppeteers in Oregon is
on NPR to create create Prosthetics that
were custom printed and they had printed and
Fredericks donated by Sony and others to to
solve a major problem and reduce the cost of
prosthetic limbs for a ton of volunteer kids
that was it that was a problem that was
solved by access to the internet. And a
bunch of people with self-interest looking
for things in there and being able to
connect if you get if you want to solve the
problems of the world get technology into
the hands of those who don't have it what
are they your next-door neighbor or they're
there in impoverished sections of a
different country or yeah medicine drawn so
sick they're so many things that could be
done with this technology
done with this technology and I just feel
like there's so much actual energy but also
like mental energy and Financial Resources
going towards this fucking crypto shit that
if we would redirect that board stuff that
actually matters instead of saying that's
what we're trying to do with the you know
stealth the agenda of actually promoting our
own bitcoin price then we would actually
make a better world and I don't see that in
the crypto world I see a bunch of false
hypocrisy in the Crypt that world and that
just drives me nuts and drives me nuts and
makes it impossible for me to stomach do I
think we still need to do it yes we still
need to explore it we still need to explore
with blockchain means for our exchange
between banking systems or between different
departments within the same company
blockchain technology for that kind of thing
is probably a very valid solution and I
think we should look at it I just don't feel
that and as as I'm not saying don't do it
it's not as simple as that I'm saying I'm
saying
let's not forget all the other problems out
there that are not going to be solved with a
non-fungible token
honestly if you know somebody else set it I
watch the video yesterday about it says why
are all the entities so ugly it's like a
really funny YouTube video and at the
conclusion the guy said that entities are
the one thing they are as a product of greed
and at the end of the day the entire
cryptomania boils down to me to Greed
unabashed hypocritical
trying to hide it you know try to trick the
other person agreed that's what it is
it's just greed at the end of the day I
don't want to lose this much of my money
they don't have rights to my money I want to
get more money I want to trick somebody else
I want to pump it up and get their money
it's it's everything all of the worst part
of stock of stocks just inflated and and
particularly of appeal to the Techno said
yeah I was too I was super interested in I
was like wow this is cool I was like hey
let's make a new internet that runs on is
hey let's do this and then I started looking
at the cost to humanity to do that and in
terms of resources and participation and and
what happens if if somebody has to have a
computer how the fuck are they going to have
a Bitcoin wallet
what you going to do with that all some of
those can hold it for them yeah right once
again my fucking computer first how about
that how about you get their their Community
a computer at the library and then you
figure out a way to hook up that came here
to the internet because if you haven't
figured that out yet you're going to try to
tell me about the value of 10 ft and crypto
get the fuck out of my face I don't want to
hear it
because you're just didn't show there's an
insincere greedy shit head that I don't want
to talk to you anymore
because you really don't care about anything
you were saying stop pretending that you
want to change the world with your solution
you don't give a shit if you actually gave a
shit you would spend that time doing a lot
low-hanging fruit and you can work on those
Solutions first but you don't care because
ultimately you want to see your Bitcoin go
up or you want to see or do you want to see
you're in after you go up because your
greeting fucker and that's all just own it
just on it called when it is and go join the
clubs with the stock people too and while
the rest of us can avoid your snake oil ass
because I don't want anything to do with it
against climate change right now yeah but
who gives a shit nobody cares contact if you
want to see there and if and if these get
pumped
are there you know they're they're trying to
get their number of viewers on Twitch higher
yeah they're going to come down all your
devices yeah
yeah I think it's funny the thing is really
funny is is watching all of this Silicon
Valley people all of a sudden get woke on
this issue Kelsey Hightower comes to mind
yeah it's like there's a ton of people in
Silicon Valley they're all of a sudden like
waking up and they're like oh and now
they're like really openly against it's
against it
how do I get there if I don't know if I want
to play that Brioni I don't know if you want
to play that
people been sending the Fiat that to me a
couple times I'm not going to play it now
yeah
yeah I don't know I don't want to hear it I
meanI mean I'm not against linking but yeah
are you looking to have a conversation they
give zero Fox they really don't
I'm serious that the biggest problem right
now is if nobody gives a shit. Yeah
tax preparer asked me if you got any crypto
disclosed yeah
he has been around forever it's the greens
not going anywhere the real question is do
we do we as a community want to enable the
greed or do we not right it's like poor
people have a big disagreement with foreign
if it it drives like 60 per-cent of the
Internet it's like there are certain things
that are just facts about Humanity that we
kind of have to accept that there's always
going to be greedy assholes they're going to
act in their self-interest and we need to
figure out how to make shit in their
self-interest so we can fix the World by the
way all of a sudden Olli Automotive makers
of all said they will never produce anything
but a hybrid car what the fuck changed
what the fuck changed
they've destroyed they destroyed the
electric car moving in the seventies it was
actually there was actually a healthy there
was a very healthy car you know electric car
movement in the seventies and it got fucking
destroy there's a huge documentary about
this because there was no money in it is all
about greed as soon as soon as it was there
was no there was no vegan option there was
no healthy chicken option you can buy in the
store for how many years what changed
people start spending her money on it boom
all the sudden all the eggs have free range
chicken on them free range this free-range
this I don't want to electric car no doesn't
make sense for me to have one and I'm going
to be living in the mountains so we have to
four-wheel drives
yeah but we don't go that far away and it's
and it's a tool and if you're worried about
your carbon footprint you know it's it's
much more important in the car you choose
at least pay attention to cost of batteries
when it comes to look at IU to it did cost
of batteries and the environment across the
batteries that's the thing is going to get
out of control but it's like not anywhere
near how bad fossil fuels are for the world
I mean come on nobody disagrees about that
no rational person disagrees that fossil
fuels are not the answer for the future and
there's not even the conservative people if
you can get them to back away from their
fighting bias position on everything if you
actually have them like really just just
really talk about the future they Envision
they don't want fossil fuels either
even the coal miners don't want to call find
a job there like we don't give a shit about
the coal mine jobs we just want a job like
it's my way to help out the most of those
things are are your way you feel comfortable
and I have I was making for many years and
the greatest thing I personally got out of
being vegan was I felt like I wasn't causing
harm but it was me personally I felt that I
could have did it really didn't really
matter the fact that I was vegan didn't
matter at all one iota to the world I just
made me feel better I think I think I think
the people that make those choices to you
also need to understand that they're making
that choice because they want to feel good
not because it's actually doing anything
your carbon footprint changing by choosing
to eat vegan is Tiny itsy bitsy teeny tiny
thing compared to the stuff that the
corporations are doing and the other thing
it doesn't even matter so just on the fact
that you're doing that because it makes you
feel good and don't be a dick about it
70% it's what I'm trying to say it's like it
if you truly if you truly gave a shit okay
so this is this is this is what I think is
funny right so it is actually a 2022 that
there's a real good satire on this there's
this guy who says he's going to go off and
protect the rainforest and everything right
and he's like all against carbon emissions
right and then they asked him they say well
we'll wait a second here like I saw you in
Cancun here in Greece he goes yeah and he
says so you went there you went there to do
activist you went there to do activism
against carbon emissions right cuz yeah and
you said how did you fly there and park
private jet
even see the problem is like he's like all
about David veganism and this and all this
and then he's like
so then he's like flying around in a private
jet was like this is the single worst thing
as individual person could do for carbon
emissions like flying a private General
around the world has yet to see what the
problem is is it mean if you really really
cared about that stuff you would choose to
not I mean if if if you think if you think
that this is Mike is very very dicey right
and I am I just a bit because nobody else I
am all about privacy rights and here I am
with my Google smartphone right I tried
using the non-smartphone for two years
couldn't survive in society I cannot survive
a suicide in my current job with a
smartphone it. Could not do it so I gave in
and I've got one but at least I want it you
know
I don't know any petrochemical and relax
until they said not to go with Misha cuz
with him is hilariously criminal absolutely
and it's like so what you going to do stop
buying fossil fuels
you stop driving your car you can drive an
electric car probably better but then what
it what are the batteries do the environment
you know it's a complicated issue and I
think
the reason that I'm talking about in this
way is because of its core nebulous way is
because
when we really and I know I've learned is
the fucking hard way I am a black and white
guy it's like you know this way and I
learned that it's not always it's very it's
always nuanced some cases it's not anyone's
right shooting someone is always wrong
unless it's a military man protecting your
children or something like that well wow
shit I guess it is nuanced
it's like yeah I don't even try to get
everyone
there's no way to be 100 right now it's
not
are exactly about it boils down to all of it
doesn't make money but if you if you wanted
to save the world
figure out how to get the greedy people to
respond
and you can't budge agree people in anything
they will fucking do anything with Bill and
and I don't even know if it's greed I think
it's I think it's self-interest bottom line
I think it's self-interest and everybody has
this superpower and that's been documented
by study from Stanford with the Monopoly
game we all have a superpower of being able
to convert convince ourselves that what we
get we deserve another words we earned it no
matter how much we've been given a certain
certain advantages so that's not agree that
self-interest so that the person who is at
1% who's running the Exxon Mobil or whatever
they think they deserve that they think that
their company deserves that they think that
they've learned that they think they they
legitimately believe in this is why I study
called mentality so much cuz I'm so obsessed
with this because people will convince
themselves of any reality that they need to
in order to survive and believe me
creamy I have convinced myself of reality
sometimes I question whether the realities
I'm convinced myself over still true
and also that's why was Mormon for so long I
am I have I convinced myself that there's no
Jesus because it's just convenient for me
now because you know and it is that a real
thing that said that exists because people
do it
that I'm a hundred percent renewable and it
karpathians in Romania well my dad this
weekend for the grid I'd repent your by the
mountain stream 102 eco-friendly I guess and
that's cool and I think if we make a bunch
of sustained decisions to do that I think
will be I think we'll be better off if
people truly want to change the world the
day it really drove me nuts is it all the
people that we're trying to do all the stuff
and then they refused to vote in any
election and I'm like I don't know I'm going
to I'm going to I'm going to I'm going to
hello
I'm going to protest I'm going to protest
this this shit by not voting
my but your vote doesn't matter it really
doesn't then America it really doesn't mean
you can see really really frustrating
statistics about how much of it really
doesn't matter but what are you doing to
change the system if anything right are you
sticking your head in the ground like I do
and playing DOTA for 4 hours are you
spending so mad at time during the week
trying to get back in a way that could maybe
educate and help others are you fostering a
problem by picking fights on Twitter you
know it's there's just so many different
ways
turn the volume restaurant out here in
Portugal yeah yeah but your wife if you
would be absolutely I would you
so that would you kidding me like that and
is a heartbeat my wife would go there
immediately my wife has actually got friends
in Germany who want her to come present
there and she might be going to gallery
gallery show in Germany or Austria at some
point we're going to be traveling again I'm
a big trouble. I used to be anyway and if if
if things keep going the way they're going
we're going to have plenty of money to go
traveling here pretty soon
I mean it's not I just found I found out one
of my wife's hair is randomly in the cuff of
my pajamas
anybody ever find that are you from
Australia brilliant producer in British
Columbia side electric yet I think
hydroelectric power can be careful that the
Hoover Dam is hydroelectric in this stuff
that they destroyed for that it's just
downright travesty nice to run rivers in
Colorado and Southern Utah
and it's either power is not completely
freeze a really great book on the building
of the of the dam and what it destroyed
yeah but
yeah China China juice China in China the
Yangtze River you guys hear about the
tragedy of the Yangtze River
oh my God yeah the AC damn is a fucking
human tragedy it's a fucking human tragedy
you kill the Killer yeah
you know I'd I think I think we need to I
think that something like streaming like
this is a step in the right direction you
just having conversations we don't scream at
each other hopefully I mean I do scream and
you scream back in
are there somebody else on the exit yeah
I think so 114 take her effort that I'm
really encouraged by
not completely convinced I'm not completely
convinced it's not because of their
spokesperson so is something called
represent us and since we're talking about
it I'm going to bring him up I have not
anything to do with them I just I'm really
encouraged by their marketing materials
which is the best way I can say that
I'm also encouraged by their spokesperson
because I love her she's one of my favorite
people to hear talk ever
and I am a massive massive
Mockingjay fan I know it's cliche I still
like it
and you guys mind if I show this this is the
reason I want you to see this is even if you
don't agree with this particular approach or
this organization the science behind
their strategy is is very interest rates
very compelling basically the science behind
making a change boils down to Grassroots
changes and it's it's really really
interesting even if you don't agree with
this organization
yeah
we pay for it
in secret lover
those who were the presidential candidates
yeah oh my God I love it she she's my
favorite actress of all time and I love
Natalie Portman to Natalie four of us
another one of my favorite
really care about this line comes from a
fence in University City
R. Kelly took their data is so crazy cool
American the vertical line that shows the
likelihood of the public support deleting an
acid of a left-leaning I think I probably am
yeah but I
I am I'm really hard to categorize
I got a positive set the reason I think that
this is important is all the problems that
exist in our world can't be in dress
addressed until our governments work
because we can't an act change without
creating laws that require the change in
Monday to changes is particularly with
corporations so
if our government systems of the world don't
work the best we can do is complain or try
to figure something out that doesn't work
with the government at all
but history has overwhelmingly shown that
governments. Are not evil they are the best
forms of of helping societal stability and
stuff the government just have to fucking
work
if you ever play the game of civilization
you get this right so you know you asked if
I was left leaning will for me to say
something like no we actually need
government
you know I'm not quite I'm not I don't I
don't think we need big government I don't
think we need corrupt government
I don't think but I don't think we need less
government either I'm not I'm not a
Libertarian wants to get out of the way and
be an anarchist and say do whatever the fuck
everybody do whatever they want
enter for your oh my God yeah I'm probably
more along the lines actually there's a
documentary it's Michael Myers people hate
him I mean Michael Moore sorry Michael Myers
is the murderer
and so Biden ties
yeah I mean if you want to categorize me and
you might who I voted for yes I would have
provided if if you think that that really
matters I wish that there's other systems by
the way out there there's actually really
good YouTube video on this there's other
political systems that do not involve
two-party politics that are amazing but we
can't even begin to discuss those until our
current governmental system we can figure
out how to make it work and then once we can
make it work otherwise we have revolution
revolution is the only option if your
government doesn't work and there's no way
to get to change to the government by going
through the governmental process there's
only one answer to that
and that's bloody Revolution usually and I
don't want to go through that
there are the parties in the US but they
don't they don't have a voice so some of the
some of the other political systems that
exist are
that that have been theorized are voting for
the issues like literally putting the issues
on the ballot and then associating the
representatives with a particular issue the
problem is the representatives lie about
what they think on every issue every time
sound tried to suggest a similar to wish
assistant American went oh my God
I heard what are actually as isn't live
working on myself face not working yeah
there's didn't feel the Bernie I tried with
Bernie is it he already has a lot of really
amazing ideas and stuff and I voted for him
two years ago the tragedy with Bernie is is
is what happened to Bernie
Bernie won the Democratic vote he wanted
straight up and they ripped it off and they
literally stole it from them if you don't
believe me you can go read it you can go
read it the number of Representatives votes
he got by the Democratic party yeah he got
he wanted he fucking what he wanted and all
the people named power they strong-armed the
the the the people that we're doing the
votes for the representatives of Democratic
party
the Democratic party into voting against the
popular vote in the district that he
represented
it was so fucked up it was so fucked up in
fact that the head of the democratic
convention had to step down because it was
so corrupt
any put Hillary in place and I am not
against Hillary it's it's just so to speak
as a lot of things about her I hate and
there's a lot of things are better than I
love just like all the party candidates let
me hear something that I really like but
burning at fucking shafted and the thing
about it is is he was too nice to do
anything about it because the nice guy
always gets the shift stick every time
there's not enough. There's not going to any
applications and then they and then they
voted in you know that they actually voting
in the you know citizens united which has
nothing to do with the citizens at all it's
all I just dated took a fall of financial
back in caps for all the money in politics
or nozzle it is no matter how much support
there is among yeah
preferences of the average American here to
have only a minuscule where is 06 kids to
clean cool
your vote doesn't matter
every single day 365 days a year for six
years to raise enough money to win
it because they've said all the laws to
benefit them
did the real question here
nearly half of Americans oh my God
this is from the politicians bragging about
the German during
86% of them are not only wonder why young
people feel that they're both of them out
because it doesn't
it's not the country if I feel like I love
her
see this isn't prom okay and this is what
I'm going to say it again
all this talk about crypto and fossil fuels
and nfc's and whether people should have an
abortion and whether people should be able
to get married when they want to all of
these really really important issues with
the people eat with this ability to job
minimum wage whether you know all of them
all these really really critical issues
can't even be dealt with cuz we have a
fucking completely dysfunctional god dammit
okay if you Idaho potatoes the B need potato
there's a whole thing on this the entire
potato industry in America is completely and
totally dependent on Prison labor if they
stopped doing prison labor in Idaho the
entire potato industry would collapse in
America completely
and there is no solution in sight we have
got all of these systems that are built up
on dependent business-driven prison systems
and prison labor that are very functional
Baseline economy is now dependent on Prison
labor and we've gotten so fucked up and so
out of control that we can't even fix it
we can't even
we can't even fix it because if we if we fix
it and we start to say offer prison reform
and stuff then the people they're going to
prison for former going to have to provide
government subsidies to the Idaho Potato
industry because they allow these
corporations to Take Over Control of the
prison systems and create these systems been
profiteering
it's it's fucking insane it's insane it's
like we are so fucked up because because
businesses have been making all the
decisions
non significant impact on public policy
yeah it's a business
listening is like I have had dreams about
Lawrence listening that's a weird I am
I have had dreams about Lawrence listening
so Lawrence lessig gives me who Lawrence
lessig is
you guys do Aaron Schwartz
I had a dream of all these all these amazing
people and I my dream was I was like having
a beer with all these like fucking amazing
so you know and
yeah
is it yet what Lawrence lessig is one as the
Constitutional scholar who reached out to
Aaron Schwartz to try to figure out how we
can improve better communication and it
created the Creative Commons that licensing
that we know today I mean it's nice he's at
Harvard but he's just amazing is amazing
human being
they all said the same thing
oh I know yep oh I know
this is such a big fucking fight this is
we're talking about we're talking about like
a mockingjay level of organization against
the capitol here we really are if if you're
going to overhaul lobbying all the money and
that series fucking power like murder you in
your sleep we don't give a shit power that
is lobbying our government to have entire
countries overthrown and to get their own
way and to silence you know is scandals
related to sex and everything like that all
the shit that goes down at this this is
where I start to sound like a conservative
because I start to sound like a deep State
person
it's not a deep state
it's a state-by-state it's a bunch of
fucking corruption is what it is and and
it's definitely a thing is definitely a
thing in this this this is the thing. People
try to Peg Me is 14 to go to conservative
one of the things I totally agree with on
the conservative side who would tend to
being a conservative side is that their shit
going on and our government that's totally
in the dark that we have no control over and
that we have to root out and they call it
deep State and all this other shit there
actually just as in bed with the Deep state
is anybody else at least the trunks were and
ends in o
yeah no way you made a transfer see this
diss lost you can almost track the beginning
of the end to the passing of citizens united
citizens united got past and that lifted the
cap off of everything else and you know what
else you can track back to the removal of
the ghost that gold standard on the dollar
under Nixon removal to go Center on the
Donut Bar Nixon and Reagan the ship that
went down with
I went down with the increasing the
Investments has stuff to put essentially
dollars into dad and then you can see the
citizens united that passed and citizens
united curse of the former Chancellor must
be accused of corruption oh God
it'll said that he would be a good asset
probably because yes connections have you
yeah yeah if anybody thinks that they're not
like fucking around big Tech is just they
just at the end of the day they know they
have more power cuz I have more money
the government's are being controlled by
money bottom line she just said it
we're going to the test with the gold
standard you can yeah what the fuck happened
that was that was that was the beginning of
the end removal the gold standard that is a
great link thank you for that that was the
beginning of the end and and everything died
after that and now big big Tech is the
closest thing to a gold standard and you
know Bubba
the Federal Reserve yeah sorry right yep
you would do that ring oven and begin to
reinstate We the People most important
influence over our elected leaders big tank
shareholders yes yes true to
yeah oh yeah big short
makes me want to watch The Big Short
this is so brilliant
I love this this gives me hope
so cool we're going out tomorrow
first of all the US Constitution gives
States sole control over how yep
I have to stop saying some there
I'm kind of giving away but they're going to
stay here but if you look at the unexpected
election wins that happened in America this
last election cycle the way that they won
including AOC and I don't care if it's a if
it's a I don't care what political Spectrum
you you look at the reason they won is
because they went to the Grassroots they
went to the Grassroots they canvassed really
crazy they got a lot of people interested
and involved and they were able to flip
their states and their election because
because they stuck they went they started
small they didn't try to go to the top and
pay crazy gobs of money to get the right
people interested in their election and get
the right advertising out they went small
I think they have
I think I think that the techniques as she's
about to talk about where what led to some
of the state's turning blue in the 2019 no
look is going to sound political I don't
need it too but the reason that some of
those States the reason that some of those
states with blue and it is because of more
participation by the population at the
low-level and so they will. They were able
to flip their local city government system
like that weather and it had been a red or a
blue movement if you can make the argument
just as equally that the reason Trump got
one is because the the conservative party
did the same thing that the other Trump
followers did the exactly the same thing
they influence the election at the small
level at the low-level they got the populace
at the low-level interested and so if you
want to flip do you want to make big changes
in a higher level you have to start small
and you have to go to the local County
elections and have to influence that and if
you get rid of gerrymandering Nassif
I've seen overwhelming I mean I don't know
I'm at that's the statistical thing but it's
I think it's pretty I believe I believe I
put that way I believe that America is
actually far more
socialist in other words we care about
issues that are associated with socialism
social issues I think that we actually care
more about those things then is fully
represented even by the people who wear
Trump that I think a lot of them would if
you were if you were to get them to dismiss
themselves from the Canada and everything
else and you were asking about what they
feel you in a non-threatening environment
they would do their responses to the
questions would be you know seen as
socialism because they they obviously want
to increase the minimum wage and things like
that but as soon as you say increase in
minimum wage to somebody who's on minimum
wage who's also a trump supporter and they
know that the minimum wage has left issue
they won't you can't get it honest answer
but if I believe I believe I have no
indication of this but I believe that that
there there's enough people in America that
statistically that would show up as you know
having interest that would align more with
Europe
or a country that would be viewed as
socialism but if you even breathe a word of
that to them they'll shoot you in the face
it's so you know
yeah
yeah I'm a nice person
this is so cool this is historically
net crazy
there's another one boom
guess what this is happening with right now
I said you yesterday name name an issue
currently that is exactly the same way right
now
the crosses party lines
no at Maxine passports it's actual weed
weed weed marijuana is like God you guys
like crazy conservative states are voting
and we'd now like recreational weed and
disease management
I want to see I want to see the prohibition
chart
right because probation came in and then I
got turned off and then it's I'm not saying
it's funny because she's picking issues that
are generally left-leaning issues people
with associated with the Left Right but it's
not just issues on the left There's issues
that her you know considered as well I would
like to see some of those
because it's a huge Market yeah it's agreed
at the end of the day
yeah the other cells politicians like hell
yeah we're going to get a ton of money on
this
it's less dangerous absolute is less
dangerous than alcohol it's just that it's
got a different risk factor though and I I
can't delete it all just get your wandering
I have massive panic attacks when I do we
calculations of federal out would require a
constitutional amendment yet so it really
does not have to come yeah if it does it
does work in Georgia that just happened did
God
yeah this is the fact that they keep doing
this shity redistricting stuff that's the
stuff they going to shut down
seriously why the fuck can we not just split
this city into regen and just say this is
how it goes down
the gerrymandering of the states I don't
know how the founding fathers would have
ever thought that was okay
both parties have been doing it forever but
people love to invoke the founding fathers
is like all perfect Univision areas of how
to do it looks as they're not they said the
Constitution should be redone every 10 years
which we haven't but if it's still even if
you you dreamt in this like you know
mythical awesome set of founding fathers do
you think they would be okay splitting
States into this shity divisions that we do
today
do you think do you think been somebody like
Ben Franklin or Thomas Jefferson would be
okay splitting of State into a fucking
jigsaw
jigsaw puzzle do you think that that was
part of the original Vision cuz I don't
think it was
but somehow we've allowed it to happen in
both parties are to blame
I just it drives me nuts yeah
the fixing this problem is possible but how
do we create our friggin on it where the
dishes while the Grassroots campaigns in the
studies that represent us we're bringing key
service
call me off for Upton and building the movie
a big movement
yes
this is why I like this movement I don't
know where it's at right now I want to go to
their stuff
people are fired up about corruption
I feel like covid is kind of taking a lot of
the steam out of this stuff
we believe the government should work for
every American not just a special info but
it's not just an idea
they had they had one in Tennessee that I
wanted to go to
I want to see this you're a the rossmont you
know rossmanngroup
yeah he's pretty famous you know about
Rossman right he's the only one against the
one he went against right to repair right
and he started going against Pearson for Bob
and guess what person was doing
yeah they're repairing to max out of the
YouTube channel right I think that's the guy
trays that uses dreams to I've seen if she
gave me the other day was screaming and
right now he's like I don't care if people
get vaccines and you know another time it
politically he doesn't really have an
affiliation but the thing I think it's
important about what happened in that whole
issue is how he caught the pierce the do you
know who knows about this stuff this is the
stuff that I think is kind of interesting a
bunch a bunch of other stuff on Street via
mash the New York rent in basketball. Yeah
he hates it but here's here's that
something that's interesting about this
publicity surrounding what happened with
that thing with the repair is he was
fighting against Pearson what was Pearson
doing
homeless person doing and where were they
doing it
I find this very very anecdotally satisfying
so one of the biggest monopolies in training
money and an in the world you know they run
County IA they run all those today plus
stuff that you know big is training
monopolize they run the corporate training
for everything and a piercing right right so
what were they doing though what did Rossman
catch them doing and where were they doing
it
I find this very very significant personally
they were lobbing they were loving at the
local city level
no they they were lobbyingthey were lobbying
at the local city level against right to
repair
I think about that for a second you have one
of the most powerful companies in history
with regard to this lobbying local city
governments
to vote in to vote against right to repair
so that they could solidify their Monopoly
saying you have to have one of our
certificates to be able to open your Mac
out the reason I think that that's so
interesting personally is because it shows
that the the powers-that-be the 1%
yeah they did the powers-that-be the 1% who
have been winning all of this time they get
this shit they understand they have very
high-powered lawyers in historians and
people that they know that help them
understand how to get change made a lobbyist
job is to understand how to get change made
it it's not just pissed I just paid money so
all of the all of the tricks that they just
talked about that her that came from the
Constitutional lawyers and academics said
her telling us how to make Institute change
in America and about Lionel historically how
every major issue is started at the
Grassroots in men up they know that and they
have been doing that stuff since the very
dawn of time and then Pearson fighting
against right to repair is a perfect example
of that when they got called out at the
local level for it
I just so happens we heard about that one
we heard about the Russ minute we hurt we
heard about Pearson trying to do their
little dirty deed at the local level so that
it would Bubble Up in and get Federal
acceptance we we start we caught them doing
it because Russ McCall them out
so so it's not just in a represent us trying
to push the movement of Grassroots to do
these these these changes at the local level
and and this is my local elections every
time somebody they go to the federal
election and then they just they blow off
the low collection cuz I don't even know
when they are
if you want to instigate change if you truly
want to Institute change you need to study
your local leaders the local people that are
there I don't even know who they were used
to study the local issues because the local
issues are the ones they're going to Bubble
Up and get power to the other people
okay I'm about done here and I'll come talk
to you
I didn't nice of you guys are so I just want
to have them my wife just got home she drove
back so all I want to say is I guess the
bottom line here I'll let it play out I'm
going to go talk to her if you really want
to make change that the main point of this
entire thing whether you go through
represent us or anything else if you really
want to change things you have to fix the
election system and you have to fix the
election system by operating at the
Grassroots which means you need to unionize
with your communities and you need to
operate at the local level don't ever miss a
local election again
because the local elections are the ones
that matter the most are the ones that fight
against gerrymandering and and maybe find an
organization like represent us or one that
you can get behind that that's bipartisan
and they are some of the events are pretty
amazing they've had you know Willie Nelson
and Waylon Jennings up they're singing
together and now they've had all kinds of
cross political boundaries for the people I
have nothing to do so I don't have any money
with invested with them I haven't ever done
any anything with them I just really like
the Mockingjay and I really like the Lord's
blessing and I really like the academic
approach to initiating change in our country
I think that their approach is sound even if
they weren't successful I think we need to
we need to think about how we can listen to
change in our government so that we can
remove the corruption so we can actually get
shit done with regard to all these other
really serious issues with that I m going to
play the snow going to go away
it should be told I hope I hope you know I
watch this and I do get a little a little
bit because I love my country I hate that
our countries owned by corrupt politicians I
hated that Russia was owned by corrupt
politicians to when I was there and I just I
feel like we can fight this the problem is
is they keep is so busy trying to stay alive
that the that we you know when we're at
we're so exhausted that we fail over to two
things like you know gaming like I do or
Witcher or talking a ranting about it and we
don't actually ever do anyting
you know we're so tired we just don't have
populations are so tired and we don't have
the money their strategies to keep us busy
and hounded and overworked and it works
religion to buy the way and we don't have a
chance to talk to act out you know it's the
same way with education you're so
overwhelmed with education pedagogy of the
oppressed they talk about that all the time
you're overwhelmed and so you don't have it
tends to rise up you don't have a chance to
look around and learn and you have a chance
to do anyting
add to our community I have not heard that
that's a pretty interesting thing but I tell
you what this this great resignation thing
that went down I think that's a sign I think
it's a good sign actually people like no I
want my life back and people are dying all
around me and I want to make something
matter out of my life and and I think as I
said before that means you know buying into
the system is much to get Capital so you can
fight against the system and make a change
and and do those kinds of things and I do
think that there's help but it it takes it a
stream of Mount of energy to do it I mean
something as simple as like streaming I
truly believe that giving more people
technical skills will get them more of the
resources that they need so that they can
free up I know it's a pipedream by the so
they can free themselves eventually to to
have more resources they have more time to
have more ability to to to to make time for
these
the things and hopefully they'll choose to
do that as opposed to just you know cop out
and put DOTA for for hours like I do it's
hard it's hard it's hard to even do a stream
that you know is not fun you know that's an
educational stream way it takes a tremendous
amount of willpower for me to try to even
keep doing this stuff but but every once in
awhile I'm encouraged bye bye things like
this way I think that's why I like
revolutionary movie so much because they
they fire me up to do something more they
fire me up to to to be invigorated to go
back into you noted to do an extra an extra
boost to to to help somebody somewhere get
the skills that they need to to stand up to
their to their to their family they might be
refreshing and leave the house and and make
more money for their family excetera
excetera and I do believe that I know
they're in code save the world that's on the
back of all my skillset shirts learn code
save the world because if you if you learn
techskills people will pay for Tech skills
too greedy people will pay for your skills
and you can use that
power for good can also use it to become
like Philthy Rich
yeah your favorite X over it again yeah
if I'm having an awesome time I am glad you
are but I literally have no energy for
anything else with me too and me too and
I've got stuff to vacuum tomorrow I am
definitely going to do something a thanks
for the follow their it takes a lot of
courage to be the fighter it really does
yeah
do they have I mean you know yeah this is
why I like studying them so much and reading
about them hey how's it going hard Londa
first job at in Oregon got nothing of such
going on so stuck on Maness work for so long
it should be nice or Glenda great thank you
for being here would love to hear your your
your you know your stuff your work day
whatever because this is how many people
here who want to move into that kind of work
and don't know what it what is it look like
in the day of the life of an SRE you know
what is it what is that day look like it
doesn't always look like my day my day is
trying to catch up right now in life and
rent and jobs yeah that's why the minimum
wages is I think the reason that they are
keeping it so low it's because if they if
people were not afraid of
we're not afraid of their health they would
do things like start their own school
systems are go directly against the school
system that's what I did I had to give it up
I had to abandon skill stack because I
couldn't survive
and that's not an exaggeration that's not
hyperbole I could not survive in America
running my own company even a minimal
company
and so I had to buy into the corporate
system they continue to provide for my
family and in doing so I had to give up one
of the greatest efforts I had going to fight
against the system that was very successful
and I could have went National with it but I
couldn't because the system is beating me
down it really is and this is my acting out
right here this is me doing this trying to
bring that forward that's why I try to do
the Boost that's why I get so bent out of
shape when people attack me for doing the
Boost and say I have alternative agenda and
then nobody should follow me because I'm a
dick and nobody should ever emulate how I
behave and you know when people say those
kind of things are very sensitive to me
because I spent my entire life and several
hundreds of thousands of dollars that is not
an exaggeration to make this happen to
YouTube to raise people up and have I failed
in the process that I've been mean yes I buy
if it had taken condescending absolutely it
kind of goes with the territory but
you know so I can go away now in fact I
think I'm going to go ahead and wrap the
stream up today let's go ahead and raise
somebody fun
it's it's okay it's okay we don't need to
dwell on it I'm going to try again don't
dwell on it and then try to dwell on what I
can change and not what people say about me
you know I'm getting the zoo is in Citrus 20
yeah let me see if we can does anybody
really obvious to rain right now
thank you for saying so let's read coating
Garden in Nice Guy
is rain coating garden and I like Himalayas
very kind he does a lot with web stuff too
so I tend to read people that are doing web
stuff because I don't really cover webself
and I appreciate you putting a good word for
me and over there I'm going to actually not
speak here so please say hello